Four,
three,
two,
one.
Ryan sickler brought some Baltimore work
ethic.
I can't believe you got actual piece of
paper that you brought.
Yeah,
I a Kamaka you.
What are you prepared?
I'm prepared.
Unprepared.
This is just shit to come back to that.
Baltimore accent is.
So when you.
I have two very good friends.
My good friend John Rollo and my good
friend.
Excuse me.
Benno Brian.
Both from Baltimore and both got the
like if you don't know.
Yeah,
that's a weird accident.
It's like,
what is that?
Hey Joe.
Hey Joe Rogan.
I love your podcast.
Jail.
It's a weird accent.
It's so fucking weird.
It's and people,
they're like hardcore.
They say shit like for sync.
They'll say zinc kitchen.
Zinc,
ambulance.
Think I um,
I didn't realize I had a southern accent
until I moved here.
And I still don't believe I have a
southern accent.
I'll give it a draw.
I'll give it a draw is a southern
accent.
But overall it's a different one.
It's not Alabama,
Mississippi,
south.
It's a friendly southern accent.
Like it's not,
it's not like,
man,
I can't talk to this motherfucker.
Right.
But it's like,
oh,
where are you from?
He's one of those.
People are always surprised when I say
Maryland.
But when you get into pockets of like a
Virginia,
they've got a southern accent there.
Even when you go into like Indiana,
there are certain areas of Indiana that
have a southern accent and other places
that don't like.
It's really weird about these little
settlements and they've just developed
these accents that just stay there.
I think Baltimore is one of the most
misunderstood though.
That's a weird one because it's a big
city.
I mean Baltimore is a big city.
They call it the big little city.
How many people in Baltimore?
If I had a guest,
couple million,
I'd say that's fair.
Yeah.
That's a big city.
Bigger than San Diego.
Yes.
Yeah.
But it's gotten older.
He's got history.
You know,
that's a lot of history.
But that weird ass accent that if you
don't know anybody from Baltimore,
you don't know that accent.
I had my buddy owns a junk yard in the
city and uh,
I took Jay back when we were on tour as
you've got to come meet him.
See this junk yard and shit and you
know,
people drop.
He's like,
oh,
we're doing everything.
And he's like,
just put a k on the end of that right
there.
Everything.
Yeah.
You guys don't know any pick you're
doing over there.
And he's also for for years I said
Washington DC,
Washer and dryer because everyone there
it says it right?
And one day somebody said,
wait,
what'd you say?
I said,
put it in the Washer and they're like,
spell washer,
w a s h e r like there's no r in that.
And I was like,
Huh?
And I started saying to myself,
I'm like,
oh my God,
I do fucking say Washington and Washer.
So I trained myself to get out of that.
But anytime I see something political on
tv,
if I hear someone say,
we're in Washington,
then I'm like,
ah,
you're in that.
You're from that area.
The same way with the days of the week.
I was telling you Monday,
Tuesday we do our podcast crab feast
comes out every Tuesday and I listened
to announcers like Phil Sims.
He's like,
well they were working out on Monday and
I'm like,
yeah,
you're from that area.
That's how I pick up little shit like
that.
Yeah.
Well I grew up in Boston.
That's an obvious accent.
Everybody knows that accent,
but you don't have it.
I got rid of it.
Oh,
so you did have shook it loose,
but if you hear me from like tooth that
early before pre 2000 I had it,
you know,
I just,
I,
I heard it too much.
I heard it in my own.
I was like iu and then they got rid of
it.
First Time I heard I was 19,
I did this thing and I was on local
television at 19 and I heard my voice,
my accent.
I was like,
what in the fuck is that sound coming
out of my mouth?
I got to correct that.
Do you ever slip into it from the
hammered?
If I'm hammered and I'm around Boston
people,
it'll come out a little bit,
but just to touch,
just to touch.
Otherwise it would be fake.
Mine comes out more like I'll go home
for a week in the summer.
I just,
by midweek I'm just talking way.
Oh yeah.
I'm home.
I'm home on the.
That's another one.
Dropping an end on the end of.
Now we're going to come over right now.
Now you swallow your ells.
You say,
uh,
get a salad and a belly.
Belly.
What do you want to have?
He's going to have a salad too.
He's out in the alley right now.
Like there's no l,
there's no l.
How it is that there's no LP.
Some people I say Baltimore with a D.
I put a touch of a d on it.
Bald Baltimore,
Baltimore Versus Baltimore.
Baltimore.
But Baltimore Bet your friends probably
say bomber.
That's how like a hardcore,
like when you ask,
you know,
out here,
you can ask anyone.
Where are you from when you ask somebody
back there to like,
they don't even say like another area of
Maryland.
Just go here.
You know I haven't left here.
This fucking block right here.
Like,
what are you talking about?
This is where I've run this fucking.
Yeah man.
There's something about me that end.
These people that are just like super
locals.
They just say,
fuck,
it doesn't miss bought.
That's another great name.
Super locals.
Yeah.
That's the truth.
This people that are like that,
right?
They just like,
this is where I fucked in my bar.
Like Denver,
Colorado.
Everyplace else can go fuck off.
People like them and it's like there's
something to that,
right?
You,
you know that spot and you're like,
I get it.
I get the rest of the country.
Good.
Good luck.
Good luck with all that.
You know.
If you didn't live here chasing those
Hollywood dreams,
what would you be?
In a perfect world,
I'd probably have a house right on the
white river in Maryland.
A salt water.
I'd have four wheelers.
I'd throw some traps out in the water on
Monday.
Oh,
crab traps and buy now.
Here's the.
This is how you say the day Saturday,
and by Saturday,
Saturday,
by Saturday we'll have a fucking crab
feast on God damn right.
Hence the podcasts,
and every week I would have my own.
I'll just throw them out there because
I.
that's one thing I really miss about
merit.
Like the Sushi out here
is phenomenal,
but the seafood,
there's different.
We could go,
we could go to a dive bar right now and
have a plate,
a bucket of rocks,
like little pony rolling rocks and a
plate of Mussels,
Marinara that will blow any fucking
restaurant out here out in a,
in a dive blues bar.
I miss the readiness of an availability
of delicious seafood
everywhere I go.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
There's not a lot of really good seafood
restaurants.
There's just Sushi out here.
Yeah,
that's a real good point.
It's like what do you get out here for
seafood?
Like some will have salmon on the menu
or maybe this like haddock or something
like that.
Or halibut or you don't know.
There's not like.
Like back home in Boston it was legal.
Seafoods was a joint 100 percent.
I mean people went to a seafood
restaurant.
Yep.
Seafood restaurants.
Not Popular out here.
No.
Why is that?
And we're on the water and then we're a
coastal fucking like,
why aren't we embrace if there's an
ocean right there embracing that.
Not only that,
you go to that ocean,
it's hardly anybody fishing.
Yup.
That's a weird one.
Like California,
like go,
go to the,
like all up by Santa Monica.
Malibu.
Hardly anybody fishing.
You might see one or two.
I just looked up best bass fishing out
here in California because my brother
just bought a place in Delaware on the
water is brackish,
but it's not enough to keep crabs.
Uh,
but he's pulling out large mouth and
sending me pictures.
I'm like,
good for you and go fuck yourself.
And he just,
I mean nice big fat ones out here.
They grow them big.
They do a,
they say mistakes.
Good because I got to get up there and
go again.
But pyramid they said I feel like
I feel like pyramid dried up a little
bit.
No,
no,
you can drive by it.
You can.
Yeah.
I drive by on the way up to,
to hone ranch.
It's a beautiful lake.
Pyramid is like one of them lost lakes
people don't know about,
but yeah,
I would live there on the water and uh,
I mean I miss my dad was an outdoors.
I was talking to you about this at the
comedy store.
My Dad hunted and stuff but fished,
but uh,
he really got us into crab and,
and not just throwing traps in the
water.
We used to,
we had a trotline we used to run a
trotline.
So this is,
if I could,
my father died when I was 16.
I've always thought about this.
If I had 24 hours,
if my dad could come back here right now
for 24 hours,
what would I do?
And we be up on the water crabbing at
5:00 AM.
Sun Up.
That's right when you're allowed to
start dipping.
And then home by 11 and then steam them
up,
have a big ass fucking crab feast and
Probably Watch a game.
I'll be like,
hey,
these are the ravens
here when you die.
And then play catch into the night.
That would be what I would do.
But we had um,
so he,
he had a friend that lived on the
eastern shore that was a crab,
a got crab or man,
I guess.
But uh,
he taught us how to do a homemade one.
So we had this,
he went and bought this jon boat,
this old Wood Jon boat,
Jon Boat,
Jon boat,
a bottom boat versus
the v bottom.
And it was wood.
I'm not aluminum.
This one was a white painted up just a
beater,
you know.
And uh,
we had uh,
uh,
Johnson Motor.
Yeah.
Every time I hear that Alan Jackson Song
drive,
he's talks about a 75 johns and with an
electric choke,
I'm like,
oh,
take me back.
So it was our boat that was our little
rig.
It's me and my two brothers and my dad.
And what you do to do a homemade,
when you take a bucket five gallon
bucket a,
or even just a smaller one,
just some quick Crete with an eye hook
in it.
Okay.
Tie your rope here to some chain,
other side of the chain,
another rope up to a clorox bottles.
That's your float on this side.
Okay.
Chain,
50 yards of rope chain,
50 yards.
Same setup.
I just told you on the other end.
So the Clark's bottles,
just so you know where you are.
That's right.
That's your beginning and your end.
And then every three feet,
and this dude was sell ahead of his time
like this.
We're talking about mid eighties,
late mid to late eighties were doing
this.
He's like,
go to the butcher and get bullets.
You know the.
Yeah,
the discarded lips of bowls,
actual bullets.
And that's going to be your bait because
crabs are the biggest scavengers you
could use.
Chicken necks are popular.
That's an easy one.
You just go to the grocery store,
but you've got to go to a fucking
butcher to get bullets.
I don't know.
Everybody's got those grocery stores.
Is it more effective?
It's just stank and nasty and like using
chicken liver for catfish.
Exactly.
But also it's durable because these
things are eating it.
That's going to be your line for most of
the summer.
You know,
you might have to replace one or two,
but that's adorable bait that can
withstand the crabs.
Tearing it up for three months.
So really three months.
Well,
if you're going out over the summer,
I'm saying,
let's say you go crabbing 10 times
during the summer,
you could probably get away with that
whole trotline,
maybe replace one or two that might slip
out because you freeze it.
So.
Alright.
So the reason the lips.
Yeah.
Well that you tie him every three feet.
Right?
And then that's your trotline big as a
bullet about that big and buff fat a
couple inches.
Well they caught him.
I'm sorry.
That's not A.
Yeah,
they'll slice them.
So they look like almost like fat eels,
you know,
little tiny or leeches.
Let me say leeches leeches.
So then you get out,
you're allowed sun up.
You're only allowed two bushel without a
permit.
A license.
So we're out there.
[inaudible] yeah.
Two Bushels.
Let's two Bushel liquid.
Is that two Bushel baskets like apple
baskets?
Probably.
But you're getting.
That's the thing is you buy them,
you'll get maybe seven,
eight doesn't.
But if you're going out,
you're throwing shit away.
You'd pay good money for it to store
because you're getting,
you're getting the best big suckers.
There is nothing better than pulling it
right out of the water and taking it
home and eating it,
not getting it from the store,
not been.
You know who,
who knows how they stored it and there's
dudes on the side of the road that when
they have more,
they'll just pour over in their pickup
truck,
put a fucking cardboard,
sign down,
20 bucks a Bushel,
and you just get them and go,
that's something I miss.
You make me hungry.
I'm doing.
These are what kind of blue crabs.
Crabs.
That's right.
So you get out,
you put a little two by four across your
or holes.
Drop your bolts in there.
That's your wood.
At the end you have an empty spool of
rope.
Okay?
Mt One,
and you just stealth everything.
We were talking about those slow riding
Harley's.
You Stealth Roger Boat and you got to be
steady.
Someone reaches over and they pull the
rope up,
put it on the Spool,
and then your natural progression
forward slowly brings the line up and
then set it back down the water and you
got to go slow because those you're
pulling those crabs up from the bottom
and they'll stay on the whole time and
then you're just fucking dip and dumping
dip and endo.
It's.
And then the title come in.
You hop out of the boat,
swim around a little bit.
You get the soft crabs,
the ones that are coming closer to shore
to molt their shelves so they can get
bigger and then those you take and we'd
get about a six,
eight of those.
Take those home crab.
You're having a time.
Your fucking lights off.
Show crabs are fantastic.
It's so good.
Those are so good with lemon and butter.
God the bus.
I love it.
That's.
That's what I would do.
That's exactly where I'd be.
Dude.
I ran into John Reape last night that,
you know,
rape is a,
he's a,
he's a road warrior,
you know,
constantly on the road and we were
talking last night.
He's like,
I'm not sure why I'm still in La.
He goes,
I don't have to live here.
He's like,
I'm here all the time.
I'm doing sets and everything like that.
He goes,
but I'm on the road man,
and I go,
where are you going to move to?
And he goes,
dude,
I'm going to get a fucking house on the
lake in North Carolina.
Oh,
I've done this and I keep talking.
You tell me more.
What's it look like?
Look like delay clears the walk,
you know,
that sounds perfect to me.
I got a buddy who's got a place in
quarter lane and uh,
they sent pictures and eat.
Dude,
you could be in like 60 feet of water
and you take a picture and you see every
pebble on the bottom of the water.
I mean it was just crystal clear.
It's like a big old bottle of Fiji.
You just see everything on the bottom.
Big Old northern pike swimming around in
there.
Yeah.
Idaho.
They fishing crab and yeah,
I've been to quarterly and I know
driving to Montana from Seattle,
come through there.
I'd Never Been Idaho.
I'm going for the first time.
I'm in Boise this month.
Right?
Right.
Soon.
Someone's sometime soon.
I love that.
I love,
I just love country.
I mean we were,
I was born in the city but we only lived
there until my parents had my younger
brother almost when we were four.
We got outta there.
I'm bigger house,
more land and stuff like that.
So you know,
you live in a row home,
there's no,
I mean our backyard was the size of this
tape,
you know what I mean?
Um,
so I grew up out in the county 20 miles
or so outside the city and my dad was
like,
look,
I want you to get a good school
education.
But all of my family was in Baltimore.
User gets where you're going to go get
your street education.
I'm so glad because I see shit from a
mile away,
a mile away.
Larson's always like,
I don't even know how you do it.
We were a,
we were at Denver,
we were in Denver at the end of 2016.
We were doing our tour and we like to
walk home from the shows at night.
We'll smoke a little joint,
take a walk,
enjoy your city,
whatever.
And he's like,
oh,
there's nothing wrong with them around
like,
Denver's got a cops episode,
Bro,
you know,
like,
settle down,
you got to
go wrong.
And um,
we're about to take this walkway
underneath this tunnel on the sketchy
fucking like white dude sketched out.
Just start circling us with those dark
eyes and his crazy smile and traffic is
hauling ass,
right?
Close bias,
And Jason,
what are we going to do?
And I was like,
we're going to stay over here by this
traffic and if that dude charges,
as I'm shoving them right into that
fucking traffic,
that's exactly what the fuck we're going
to do.
I'll bait them over here.
Just shove them right out there and let
those cars.
Because he said good night.
He said,
Shit.
He was saying shit like that.
And I was like,
oh,
one of those guys.
Yeah.
What do you do if you kill someone like
that to tell anybody?
Like it was just you and Jay?
Well,
these days everything's on camera.
What cameras?
There's.
There's eye in the sky,
but if.
Oh yeah,
I would tell you.
Yeah,
will tell that one.
I will because I feel like that's self
defense if you're,
if you're.
Even if you're leaning toward me to
wrong when you say they bring it up at
your show.
Hey Bro,
people
kill any veterans.
Shove a guy,
kill many veterans.
You know the guys at veterans,
what if he is could be ptsd all fucked
up.
And then I started moving.
Careful.
Maybe the guy just needs a hug.
Problem is you never know.
Not when you say shit like that and
you're certainly circle.
And he circled us like four times.
Just kept circling.
I hadn't thought they asked if he wanted
a hug.
I'm gonna.
Try this shit.
Yeah.
When you hear I was stabbed to death on
the sidewalk endeavor.
Just.
No,
I tried to hug it out.
Yeah.
You ever been outside of Denver?
Like Evergreen?
Ever go up there.
I've been to know.
I haven't been to evergreen up into
Colorado Springs.
Evergreen has,
uh,
the northern pike has a cousin,
the Musky.
It's the evil cousin,
the eat ducks and shit.
Ever see a musket lunch?
No dude,
they eat.
They're prehistoric.
I'm gonna.
Look,
that shit is a giant ass fish.
But when I was up there the week I was
up there,
someone on facebook or something like
that,
I was like,
I was like damn evergreens,
beautiful.
This place is gorgeous and I just was
looking up shit on evergreen and I saw
some guy pulled one through the ice that
was fat around like a girl's waist cv.
Get this.
Holy Shit.
Big Ass animals could eat a duck.
I caught that one in Wisconsin.
Yeah,
looking at one above it.
Looking at one above it.
Look at the size of that and they look
like tigers.
The stripes.
It's a tiger meets a python.
Meets a fish.
Yeah.
That's an evil fish.
They're fucking prehistoric in their
ruthless man.
I mean are you.
I feel like you'd be fighting that thing
like a Marlin for like two hours.
Yeah.
You.
Especially if you have light tackle,
do you need to be strapped in a chair
for that thing?
No,
but look going to battle.
Hold that.
Well,
yeah,
you're going to battle.
You're going to battle.
Look a fucker.
Oh,
that's not a,
that's not a mosquito.
That doesn't look like a mosquito.
To me that looks like a Gar.
What does that.
So the caption says are a pie.
Oh,
our apartment.
Yeah.
That's that gigantic fish that lives in
Bolivia and Ecuador.
That our apartment is a fish that lives
in the Amazon,
I believe somewhere in the rain forest.
And um,
they used to,
the locals used to catch them all the
time.
It was like a big thing for their food,
but they're worth so much money for
Americans to go down and fish for them
and now they protect them.
Uh,
my good friend,
Steve Rinella has a podcast called
mediator and he went down and filmed
episode.
He also was a TV show and they filmed
some episodes of their show in Peru and
in Bolivia.
And um,
those people,
the locals,
they make a whatever money did,
they actually do make.
They make a big portion of it.
Some of them do.
I'm helping people fish for these
things.
Um,
you know,
like acting as a guide the size of these
things,
look at that prehistoric giant animal
and they survive in water when there's a
drought.
So when the water gets like super low,
they're surviving and water were like,
literally,
like the water's up to their half their
face and they're waddling around so you
could just walk right up to him and
catch him.
Damn.
I want to walk up to anything with teeth
like,
well,
they don't have teeth as big as the,
uh,
the muskies.
If you go back Jamie,
to those pictures,
let's see.
There's a bunch of them in like water
where their upper body's exposed.
Yeah,
the water's so shallow and they're so
enormous.
I mean,
these are huge,
huge dinosaur fit.
Yeah.
There's,
you ever seen a Gar?
Do you know what a garlic side pull up
an alligator gar alligator Gar is.
Um,
that is a truly priest,
oric fish.
Like I don't think it's changed in
millions and millions of years.
That's an alligator.
Had never seen nothing in my life.
These things live in Texas.
They live here in the states.
Yeah.
People fish for them and they get
fucking man.
Look that that one right there is clear
that as an head of an alligator in the
body of a fish,
it's called a what?
An alligator Gar and their body is
armored.
Like there's those scales.
You have to cut through them with wire
cutters.
Like if you try to cut through that shit
with like a regular,
like a buck knife or something like
that.
No offense to book,
you know,
like a Swiss army knife for some shit.
It's not good enough,
man.
Look at the size of that one.
That guy is holding in the,
in the water.
Look at that fucking size of that thing.
Pull up giant alligator Gar.
See if you.
Because I think that.
I think they get into the hundreds of
pounds.
I mean,
what are you catching these with?
What is Bait for this?
Like it's a good question.
Something big
Jesus Christ,
but they look at the one in the upper
right corner.
Him in the mouth.
Look,
adapt.
Fuck.
If I saw a glimpse of that pop up out
of,
I cut my own line,
I'd say,
fuck that.
Fucking look at that thing.
It's such a creepy old dinosaur.
I mean at towers over that guy.
It's not even close.
Eight feet,
three inches long.
Two hundred and 30 pounds.
And that's a freshwater animal.
Two to 300,
27 broken bow lake,
Oklahoma
is so to dolphins stuck together.
Look at a fuck.
And you look at that.
That's an edible cut through this good.
You cut through all that.
They caught that one in Nicaragua.
So I guess they're all everywhere.
But um,
yeah,
you take them,
you got to cut through that scale,
that scaly outside with wire cutters.
And then once you get through all that
you,
you take the meat and they really liked
smoking it.
They put it on a smoker.
That's apparently the best way to.
This guy's a little baby ones in his
fish tank.
There are vicious little creature.
I mean they actually stay.
I mean that's what's blows me away as
they start that small.
Yeah.
And he's fucking with them right here.
Yeah,
we mean you can.
I think you can have them in a fish
tank.
Oh,
he's feeding them a fish.
Oh yeah.
That's a whole fish.
Yeah.
Dinosaurs.
How long have alligator guards been
around?
Find out.
I think.
I'm going to guess.
I'm going to guess 30 million years.
They've been that way.
It might be more $30.
Million alligators I think has been.
They've been around before the
dinosaurs.
Straight down and they've been around I
think in the same forum since.
Before that meteor hit looking like
that?
Yeah,
I think so.
I might be wrong.
First description is 10.
Oh,
three.
The first description of them.
Yeah,
but like how long have they been in
that?
I don't know how you find that out.
How would you find that out?
Whatever.
Oldest fuck.
Dinosaur fish.
I mean I'm used to seeing those people
pull out big carp and catfish,
but I've never.
I've never seen anything like that.
Yeah,
those are big ass fish.
They bow hunt for them too.
That's what I was going to ask you.
That one picture looked like it had a
bow in it,
so they do.
A lot of people do that,
go in those those rivers and they do it
at night too,
that they'll have like spotlights.
So you see the fish in the water,
you're shooting something and it's like
six feet away from you and they use like
recurve bows that are made designed just
for both and they have like a spool on
it and shoot it into it and then they
just pull it in by hand or they have a
real say how they pulling that thing
wherever 300 pounds it takes forever.
Yeah.
There's some videos of guys catching
them.
It's fucking crazy.
When you watch them fight these things.
See if you get a video of a guy catching
an alligator Gar kinda test line.
You got to have for an alligator braided
braided line that they have that like
heavy duty braided line and they use a
leader like a wire leader.
Big Ass fucking hooks go for up to 40
grand for a aquarium and the Japanese
black market,
it says 40.
Those little ones,
like we just saw the size,
it just says that the 40 grand in Japan.
Huh?
Fifteen to as high as 40.
Oh,
just say black markets.
It's probably illegal.
And there's an article if someone
getting arrested for it.
Dude,
that was.
I'm in Maryland.
This thing happened,
I don't know the full story,
but it was called snake heads.
Um,
and I think somebody put them in the
water.
They're from Africa and they bred.
Wow.
That thing.
Yeah.
They,
they take over those snake heads.
That's a real common thing.
And sometimes what they do is they'll
poison everything in the lake to kill
the snake heads and then start from
scratch and the restock the lake.
So that's definitely somebody put that
in there.
Yeah.
Yeah,
definitely.
I think snake heads,
like I said,
I think they're from Africa,
but they're from somewhere else for
sure.
This.
Yeah.
This guy he's got.
Oh,
walk in monster on there.
How do you get the hook out of the
mouth?
Maybe it's just too tired by the end.
It just gives up.
May Look at that.
Yeah.
But again,
they are good to eat this.
Apparently they taste delicious.
Especially when you smoke them.
It's got to feel good to fight that
thing all day.
Bring it in and eat it.
That's got to feel good.
I've got some pretty good size fish,
but nothing like that.
I kind of Marlin,
once they do that was like a 70 pounds.
Not,
not a giant one know.
But it was like five minutes into
fishing.
Yeah.
How long did it take you to bring it in?
About a half hour.
That's damn good.
Yeah.
It wasn't that big.
Seventy pounds from Marlin.
I'm not.
The biggest guy in the boat said that
they've caught him close to a thousand
pounds a thousand.
Your mom,
I think.
I think they go a thousand pounds.
They're fucking huge.
Like what do you think?
What's the World Record Marlin?
Find that out.
Like right off of Malibu.
Malibu sport fishing.
It's a great place to go fishing.
It's just there's not a lot of people
out here that go.
I went deep sea fishing,
so while ago now off of A.
I think it might have been out of
Huntington.
We rented a boat just like six of us.
The world record is 1,376 pounds caught
off Kona in 1982.
Woo.
That's a big,
big
fish.
Dam Twenty.
Damn man.
I mean that's a boat.
Yeah.
As a giant fish and they fly through the
air two and you're fighting them.
That's pretty sure that they get up.
Yeah.
I went deep sea fishing out here.
It was like six of us because I didn't
want to do the,
you know,
fucking everybody leaning over your face
and stick and,
and shit.
So we go out here,
it's in the more,
you know,
before the sun comes up and we're
heading out to meet the,
the sardine boat that's coming back in
that's going to sell bait everybody and
we're getting everything.
All these guys knew what they were
doing.
Everything fresh,
everything fresh.
And just as the sun starts coming up,
we hit a pod of dolphins.
I mean baby ones,
everything.
And I just was like,
if I don't catch a fish all fucking day,
this is app already worth it.
I mean,
they're just right next to his playing,
playing,
um,
and if this guy was so good,
if we didn't drop our line and pull
something up on the first one,
he played,
pick them up and he did take us with his
depth finder,
go find something else and we'd go by
those big boats,
have everybody reaching across and be
like,
look at that guy.
So that could be you.
Today we're having a beer,
we're having lunch.
I didn't know,
I just never considered it,
but I didn't know a fish could get the
bends.
It fucked me up when I'm selling.
Yeah,
because the eyes were all.
It looked like it at a tongue sticking
out and shit.
I'm like,
what says?
He's like,
you gave it the bends.
I'm like,
oh,
that makes sense.
I'm bringing it up and I guess a fish
can get the bends,
but best fucking fish.
So guy,
you know,
on the way back in,
he's cleaning it.
Packs it all.
Nice for you.
It's not here.
It was out here.
Did you go?
It was awful.
Huntington,
I think out of Huntington beach there
was like a pro,
you know,
just hit them up and it's like a dude
and owns his own boat and he's like six
of you come,
you know,
we'll have plenty of room.
You guys can walk to the front and back
of the boat,
fish wherever you want.
You got a choice to either chum for
shark or fish and he's like,
it's ours a me chumming it's,
it's Kinda boring until we actually
start getting at it.
So if you want to fish,
we'll do this.
And we did that through packs it all up.
So nice for us.
I'm all excited.
I just moved out here and not long.
I'm living in this dump in north
Hollywood.
I put my fish into fucking freezer and a
fridge.
What I've never done,
I've never.
It's stuck so bad.
I called my buddy.
I'm like,
I'm coming over to have some of your
functions
all ruined.
But it was,
it was such a good time.
Such a careful eating sharks today.
People get mad at you for sharks.
Really?
Yeah.
That's a new thing.
People think that sharks are endangered,
they seen so many things about shark fin
soup that if you pull on a shark,
people get angry at you.
He used to be biddable caught sharks and
no one gave a fuck.
They saw jaws.
They're like,
fuck shark.
But now everyone,
we have to save the sharks.
Save 'em say this sharks,
what are you doing with that chart?
And let it go.
Um,
there was uh,
a photo of.
Was it the governor of New York or the
mayor of New York City?
One of those,
I think it was the governor of New York
caught a shark and people were pissed at
him and he's like,
no,
we fucking ate it.
We cooked it up.
We ate it.
Shark tastes good.
Like it's totally illegal.
Like just had it in restaurant.
Yeah.
Good.
But people are loony with shit.
Like,
here it is.
What is this
heard about?
That he got his dick bid off.
Yes.
I just saw this
guy rips off his penis despite
horrified,
sunbathers frantic battle to save his
life under Brazilian beach,
g zealous.
And apparently this is a really,
really rare attack.
They don't get a lot of attacks in
Brazil because the water's so warm,
but apparently that shark didn't get the
menu.
Clearly.
I,
I thought I saw.
They thought it was a tiger shark.
That's a fucking shark shark.
Well,
obviously I'm a bit bit his pelvis off,
right with a dick goes.
I can't even.
I mean,
that's basically like your leg.
You're swilling around and just gets in
between their
snack.
Fuck.
Fuck that man.
I just,
that's.
It scares the shit out of me about the
water man.
That you don't.
You don't even see it common.
At least if you're in the woods,
you kinda hear thing is.
That's right.
You got the hearing.
You don't even have that gun.
You know,
you know what's out there.
Nothing out there is ground in the
ocean.
You know what I mean?
Right here.
She'll hear shit until it's too late and
then this will.
It's you,
you read in front of your face.
You're like,
fuck,
this is how it's going to end.
All those road gigs I did.
Oh,
go on my airline miles airline miles
ago.
Open mikes
go out like this.
You know,
um,
I've been thinking about this and
talking about this on stage a little
bit,
but the,
as far as depth goes to go out of the
most beautiful way I've ever seen any
creature on this little rocket outer
space go out.
The most original beautiful way is that
dove that got killed by Randy Johnson.
It's the best death on planet earth.
What are the odds of.
That's what I'm saying.
That place at that time.
Do you know how many billions of fucking
birds have been on this planet?
You know what?
They died of,
uh,
Randy Johnson fastball one,
one,
one.
You could even narrow it down to how
many birds were in that area that day.
I don't care that one one.
And when he hit it,
it blew up into its own.
Like fireworks went out.
Kapo was like,
Oh yeah,
there it is.
It's there.
I know this.
It fucked him up.
Did it?
Yeah.
And then he ended up winning.
They won the world series.
This is in spring training.
The same year they won the world series.
He won co Mvp,
I think he split it with curt schilling
and um,
now he's got it.
I just looked this up recently because
he's got a company now and I think he
uses the logo of like an upside down
burden is embraced it,
but he was like,
that's not funny.
I don't think that Shit's funny.
You know,
he threw 100 mile an hour fast ball.
I mean pieced.
He was a fucking beast.
Now let me ask you this.
What do they do?
How do they,
how do count that pitch?
They stats.
It's just considered a dead pitch.
They said it was a no pitch,
rolled it off like we're going to reset
on that.
Wow.
Was,
was randy fucked up like it bothered
him.
I mean,
he talked about it like people were
making jokes and shit and he was like,
I don't think that Shit's funny.
Uh,
but
it's beautiful.
Even if you don't think it's fun.
It is fun.
Well wonder what they did with the dunk.
They should cook it because doves are
delicious.
I've never have had pheasant.
I've never had dove pheasants.
Delicious.
But dove is a highly,
people don't know that it's another one
that people get angry if you bring up
pheasant or because it's a bird of
peace,
but it's a highly prized game.
Bird,
like people go dove hunting and they'll
shoot fuckloads of doves and take them
home and cook them.
And He tell people that they get so
angry.
Like,
what are you doing?
You're cooking doves.
Stop it.
You want some chicken?
I'll have the chicken prisoners ground
up into small cubes,
but not the dove.
The dove is about peace.
That's it.
It's a fucking bird.
It's just a bird.
Has No idea what it is.
Like.
Oh,
don't eat that eagle.
Okay.
I won't eat the Eagle.
Eagles get so plentiful that like
pigeons.
Do you think they'll let us eat?
Eagles?
No.
Never.
Never going to let you touch.
He never.
I don't care if they're starting to
attack us and lift us off.
They're not letting us touching it that
way.
Here
they were here first.
The Ego was in North America before the
white man.
They were here first.
Yeah man.
Um,
I have friends that live in Alaska.
You go up there,
dude,
and you see eagles everywhere.
Just fucking everywhere.
They're everywhere.
They're like pigeons.
Weird.
It is.
I had this moment.
I'm so,
I didn't even think.
I'm so glad you said that.
I,
um,
my daughter's mother,
her family is from Seattle and they live
right on Lake Washington.
They're good friends.
Bill Gates is around the corner.
It's beautiful and they do this.
It's called seafarer weekend where all
the boats come out,
blue angels,
the whole nine,
like beautiful.
And they rehearse for like a couple days
before the actual event.
So I swim out into the middle of.
I smoke a joint,
the beautiful Pacific rim.
We,
they have up in Seattle and I smoke a
joint and I swim out into the middle of
Lake Washington.
I'm just out there treading on my back
float and having a good time.
And they had been saying there's this
bald eagle that had been circling.
It's got a nest,
a couple houses up,
whatever.
I swear to fucking God.
This is the God's honest truth.
There's a boat also for people who see
it to two eagles come out together in
tandem as a team.
One of them start circling here,
this motherfucker nose dives into the
water.
I'm in,
grabs a fish and flies off.
And I said,
Oh,
oh my God.
Like it was um,
and the people in the boat or clap
clapping.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
It was
fucking amazing.
Wow.
Amazing into the water.
I was and boom,
out.
And they work together.
I don't.
I mean I have no,
I to just sorta snatched him.
He gone beacon and out peak.
So maybe it was feet.
He might've went his feet.
He had to go feet.
He went feet and boom.
Lifted it off.
But his solid feet in real life.
Their town.
The fucking trigger in our hands.
Yeah.
It's like a giant basketball player.
Hand with clause.
Cause I've seen those videos online
where they like lift toddlers up and
start to fly away.
But they're a little too heavy.
I don't think so.
No.
I think that's been proven that those
were horseshit.
That's bullshit.
What about this?
I've seen the goat.
That's dropped one down amount.
That's.
Yeah,
that's Golden Eagles.
They're the biggest ones.
They're bigger than bald eagles.
They grab them and they.
I think they even have those in
California.
Believe it or not.
Golden Eagles learn a lot today.
Yeah.
This fucker about this one.
This.
So Fox.
Fox.
Fox has got his little boom.
The Eagle comes and snatches him.
It's like,
no bitch.
Let's go.
No,
no,
no.
I'm hanging on motherfucker.
I'm hanging on motherfucker and the
eagles like,
all right,
bitch.
I'll let you go.
Yeah.
It's funny that that's our national
animal because it is a ruthless fucking
flying cunt is.
It's heartless.
You look in their eyes is just death.
Yeah,
just twitchy eye.
Fucking death.
Big Old Flying Lizard.
You do a good ball.
You go with a hatchet for a face.
Just kinda pair of bolt cutters for a
face.
I watched this.
They had this video online.
It was live videos of bald eagles having
babies and you could watch them.
They had cameras set up on them and
everything.
It was fascinating.
It ended.
It ended terribly though.
The they showed you how the mom would
sit and the dad would go out and hunt
and then he came back and he would just,
his shift was like an hour or two and
she was the rest of the time,
but he would go out and bring food back
and the poor thing,
I think it was the mom going to get
food.
It got fucking hit by a commercial
airline.
Got Hit by jet on a landing and killed
the mom.
Oh Wow.
And so they had to help the birds
because the dads don't go,
you know,
that would've been the end of their ass.
So I think that'll,
I don't know what they do.
They might.
They're savage fucking birds.
Bird Ravens to.
I learned about ravens being a raving
fan.
I watched this documentary one time,
just the fucking lady in England had a
rave in a pet.
Raven,
you know,
that British,
that little that it's like an upside
down u.
That car,
that weird old car.
It's just a,
it's just like a little,
like a parentheses upside down.
Yeah.
This,
she had a pet raven.
That was,
they said,
I guess they're the most intelligent
bird and this thing.
She would keep the keys in the ignition
and the windows down and she'd be like,
we're going to go for a ride,
and the raven would fly into car,
start the car with its beak,
sit on the door.
She'd get in,
she'd start driving,
and then he would just fly right next to
the car wherever she.
It was unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
I could knock it over it.
So she had like a relationship with this
100 percent and this raven knew and
loved it.
Like he was like,
Oh shit,
let me go start the car for you.
She would say,
let's go for a drive.
And the Raven knew what she was saying
out out,
boom in the car,
grabbed that shit with.
It's because they're big.
They're big too,
and just turn those little keys and he
would wait for her to get in.
She'd start driving.
You just fly right next to it.
I don't know.
You might look for it,
but I watched it.
They're.
So I saw video one using a tool to get
another tool.
So that it could get into something like
they did these tests to find out how
they intelligent they were to see if
they could do problem solving to get
food and so it had to use like one small
stick in order to pull out a larger
stick and the larger stick to pull out
this thing that got them the food and
they figured it out and figured it out
quick,
quicker than my kids would have this
much of this raven like damn this thing
smarter than an eight year old.
It's crazy.
It's crazy watching it do it.
It's like this little conniving fucker.
There's a great video.
One of my favorite videos online of this
one.
Raven that taunts these two cats into a
fight.
It stares at them up into a fight.
Yeah,
they're both.
What is this lady?
Go raving crazy bitch.
Whoever you are,
if you stick your penis in that lady,
you deserve everything you got coming to
you.
Everything.
What the fuck?
You fix it in that bag.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
Look at that heads.
Heads.
Baby heads is dude over here.
Just chill.
And like it's nothing.
Yeah.
That look on her.
If the guy next,
he's just checking his twitter,
he probably doesn't even know.
He hasn't even looked over.
Nobody sitting next to that bitch
though.
Like I'll stand all the way I look at
it.
I mean everything about her looks weird.
She's like,
when do I kill myself today?
Not Today.
When she looks crazy.
Pitch with metal over boots.
Show your goth.
Hold it.
What does it say?
Sure you're goth by.
But are you dejectedly riding the subway
with
the bar right there.
Everybody.
See if you can find the raven provokes
hats.
It's one of my favorite videos because
there's just two cats and they're on
opposite rooftops,
like right next to each other.
And they're like,
wow,
look at each other's raven comes over
and fucks with one of the cats.
Like,
come on man.
Come on man.
It is.
So the cat's chillin.
And then the raven flies over to where
the cat is and starts fucking with him.
And after he starts fucking with them,
then he flies over to where the other
cat is and he starts fucking with him.
So he gets behind and he's like,
hey bitch,
what are you doing?
He gets just close enough with the
Catholic mother fuckers.
Like none.
Anoma fly back over here and gonna fuck
with this cost.
But he's doing it on purpose.
It's a little cut.
Like you could tell.
He's just getting the cats riled up.
Hey Bitch,
look,
I'm a bird and I'm right behind you
motherfucker.
He's cats like,
no,
no.
I'm going to get this other cat.
And then looked at each of the cats
like,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
No,
fuck you.
Look,
he's keeps getting closer to the cat.
Why would a rave and get close to a cat?
I mean,
why?
Why would any bird?
Yeah.
The only reason why is because he's
fucking with him.
He's doing it on paper.
Him,
you know,
it gets over there.
There was like,
oh,
now it's happening.
Oh,
they fall off the roof together.
Flies down.
He's right next to my faggots.
These cats are killing each other.
And this rave was like,
you dumb hose.
Oh look.
They fall into that hole.
Now,
raven is just hanging out with them,
an animal that can fly on the ground
vulnerable.
Watching these two cats fight two steps.
He jumped into the whole.
That is a crazy ass bird.
That is a crazy fucking bird,
but also confident,
right?
He knows how quick he can move.
He coming in from the side like that
happen at his tail.
He's like,
no,
you're not done yet.
That cat is still alive,
motherfucker.
What kind of a pussy are you?
It's such a weird,
weird animal.
Like once they found out that these
things are smart,
they're like,
look in comparative tests when it comes
to like problem solving there are as
smart or smarter than chimpanzees.
Ravens.
Yes.
Yeah.
Here,
here's what I hear.
They're super smart,
super smart.
Like they don't know how smart that the
limitation is that they've got these
feet and wings,
but if you gave him like fingers in had.
I'm like,
problem solve stuff like spell their
name and Shit and you know,
you give them some food.
They might be able to do that because
chimps can kind of do stuff like that.
Here's one.
Look at this Raven,
a crow crow,
raven pro.
Pretty set.
What is the difference?
Is the Raven bigger?
Yeah.
A lot bigger.
Yeah,
but they're all smart.
So this little fucker realizes that if
he puts these rocks in that water,
that the water float up and he'll be
able to get that food so you can't quite
reach that food.
So he keeps dropping those rocks in
there to try to raise the level of the
water up.
How the fuck does he figure that out,
man?
Like,
look at that.
That's crazy.
Oh,
I said he's like,
no,
not quite.
Almost almost
wish I could just get it.
Oh Gosh.
Light versus heavy.
What does this all kinds of experiments
with them.
Oh Wow.
Look at that.
It says it's a casual understanding of
water displacement by a cro.
Is the name of the video
study done by Auckland,
New Zealand.
The university will just makes you
think,
right?
Like we always define intelligence by
how much can they manipulate and its
environment.
And where that throws us off is like
dolphins and orcas and whales because
they're really smart and they can't.
They can't do anything.
They have flippers,
but we know they have these really
complex languages and Qa and they have.
They have Baltimore accents.
Do you know that dolphins,
dolphins,
and orchids have accents do that?
Yeah.
I can tell.
They can't tell what the fuck they're
saying,
but they can tell where they're from
really.
So it's a regional thing,
not like a bottle.
Nose versus a spotted has a different
accent from different spots of the
world.
They have different accents.
They make different sounds.
No Shit.
Yeah,
I know that.
We used to fuck with bats when we were
little.
You ever mess around bats?
No,
but I've been in Austin for the largest
migration in the northern hemisphere.
I think Austin has the largest
migration,
like its largest daily migration of bats
in North America.
Daily.
Yeah.
It's crazy when it gets dark out.
Look at all those bats.
They fly out from under the bridge.
There's A.
There's a bridge in downtown Austin,
Bro.
It's crazy.
So we're staying in this hotel and
they're telling us,
hey,
when it gets dark out,
that bridge over there,
they're like all the bats nest in that
bridge and they come out.
So during the daytime I was with my
family with walked under the bridge and
you hear that cluster is hanging
underneath the bridge.
You go under the bridge here.
That shit.
Look at that dude.
It's millions.
Millions and millions of fucking bats go
flying through the air.
It's crazy to watch.
What is it about?
What does it say there?
What does this pull it back to?
The beginning it says from March through
April,
millions of mostly female pregnant
Mexican,
free tailed bats migrate north,
give birth the new Congress Avenue
Bridge in downtown Austin,
Texas is the spring and summer home to
these bats.
Each night at sunset,
some 2 million bats venture out from
under the bridge to eat an estimated
30,000 pounds of insects.
It is the largest urban bat colony in
North America.
And then he watched the departure play
that video.
Cc this departure.
It's fucking bananas,
Dude.
You can't believe how many bats fly out.
You're like,
what?
That they all just pick this one
neighborhood.
There's one bridge.
They decided this is our spot,
and so they just live in this bridge,
so somebody detonated that bridge.
Look at that.
It looks like night.
It's crazy,
dude.
It's crazy.
I was there for this is.
It's wild to watch.
You just see them like like a swarm like
insects.
How are they not running into each other
like that?
Knocking themselves down.
That's a good question.
Look how tight that is.
A head butt.
Each other people could barely get on
the subway together without stepping on
toes and things are flying fly.
They say that they have some sort of a
magnetic sense.
They understand like there's a frequency
that each one of those animals gives
off.
That's how birds do it.
Like they ever see birds.
They move together in these crazy
patterns.
Yeah.
No one understands it totally,
but one,
there's a company called Hex h e c x a
hecs and they make this thing called a
heck suit.
It's a very controversial thing,
but what the idea behind it is that
there's an electric frequency that all
humans and animals and especially like a
predators game,
animals give off and that this,
this frequency is it corresponds to the
movement of your muscles and that you
give off this thing that that animals
can see,
especially predators like predators.
Apparently a really good at seeing this,
but holy shit.
Where are these local stores
say now?
I've been through something like that in
Maryland.
They used to have a while.
They don't.
They.
They do.
The cicadas would come through and it
would look like this and they would
litter the streets and the sidewalks.
Well,
locusts.
That just grasshoppers under certain
conditions.
Right.
How does that work?
Grasshoppers under certain conditions
become locus.
Yeah.
I forget.
I mean in five seconds he just filled
that Netapp.
Yeah.
What do you do with them though?
You eat them.
Eat them.
I don't know if I'd eat that.
I'm down to try different shit.
Yes.
I've had cricket chocolate covered
though.
Mexico.
We stayed at a resort once in Mexico and
you go into the hotel room,
you know,
they have like a little table there and
they have like a little table full of
peanuts with like,
um,
like some hot,
like hot chili powder on them and stuff
like that.
And then they had these crickets in a
bowl and my kids like,
why do they have bugs?
I'm like,
you're supposed to eat them.
They're like,
no way,
you're not eating bugs.
I'm like,
I'm telling you these this year,
they eat these things.
And so I picked him up and I started
chewing them.
I'm like,
they're not bad.
They're like a,
almost like a soy sauce tastes.
How,
how are they done?
It looks like they fry them,
like they fried these crickets,
but they're so common that they had a
bowl of them in the room,
you know,
and eat them.
You know what I would try that.
I would try to,
I would try that,
but I'm scared of that.
They say that that might be one of the
futures of,
uh,
when the weather changes,
grasshoppers turned into,
oh,
it's a weather issue.
Thing I clicked on this from says that
just by swarming it makes them become a
locus.
That's it.
I don't know if that's accurate,
but that's what the article is saying.
Oh,
well it's The New York Times,
unless you listen to Donald Trump,
which fake news,
right?
Generally speaking,
I like to trust in New York Times.
Yeah.
We used to fuck with us,
so we had a light,
a street light in front of our house and
um,
my brother and I would go out and my dad
was like,
you can go out and play catch as long as
you're in front of that light and I can
see you.
So we just go start playing catch,
throw a tennis ball round one night.
We're just thrown at high up toward the
light so that you could see it coming
down.
And this bat just starts sweeping at the
ball the whole time.
And I was like,
oh,
this is great.
So I throw a line,
drive it my brother's fuck of faith,
that fog of battle.
It went right through his hair that the
gay became became.
You got to be a fucking man.
It's take that shit at your face and
that
would come down.
It would touch you.
You think the ball was another bad?
I don't know.
I maybe all the sonar coming after that,
you know,
I don't know if it thought it was a big
or realized it was a too big of a bug
when it got there,
you know.
But it would,
it would hit,
it would come right by your fucking face
man.
Probably thought is another bat or maybe
something to eat.
Yeah.
Wow.
So anyway,
I was seeing this heck suit.
They were these things to destroy their,
their big with people that go spear
fishing and they wear this suit and you
can like literally get right next to a
fish with his suit on.
It's real weird.
Like whatever this,
whatever this frequency that human
bodies and bodies in general give off.
This suit masks it and they've been able
to show that with these devices like
that measure electrical frequencies.
You can rub your arm over Shit,
look like these alligators.
They just,
for whatever reason,
don't fuck with this dude while he's
wearing that.
That's a crocodile to do that.
Even though you're moving and there's
what you are and they just don't bother
to understand that it figured out.
I Dunno,
scientists,
super smart dudes,
but when apparently dudes wear these
suits,
when they go spear fishing,
they're way more successful.
They love these things because you can
get like right up next to these fish and
fuck them up,
but hunters used them to.
Now they're.
They're becoming popular with hunters.
Oh,
so they don't work just in the water and
I don't know man.
I've worn them before.
I don't know if they're working or not
working,
so it's hard to tell because what
animals go by is not one thing.
They go buy a bunch of different things.
The the big one is smell.
If they smell you,
you're fucked.
Like the reason why Cammo works is cammo
breaks up your outline,
like have like a deer saw you.
They'd be like,
oh,
that's a fucking do.
That is.
I see the arms,
I see the leg,
that's a dude.
But if you were on camera with all the
broke,
like my shorts,
like these shorts broken up pattern.
Right?
So that broken up pattern confuses them.
They were like,
what is that?
I don't know what I'm seeing.
And if you just stand still and you were
in Cammo and you don't move a dear look
at you and go,
I mean shit.
And they'll go back to eating unless
you're close,
but the smell you.
They're like,
fuck this.
Yeah.
Especially that real tree stuff.
I see these days look so authentic.
Like that's not the stuff that works the
best is not interesting.
No.
Authentic is not what works the best.
What works the best is like there's,
there's a,
a bunch of different companies that make
really good camera,
but the secret behind it is just
breaking up.
The outline doesn't have to look like
anything.
It's just a matter of like breaking it
up with like blotches and spots and
there's a couple of companies like under
armour actually has a really good
pattern.
It's called rich reaper,
reaper baron,
and that pattern is really good.
Sitka has probably the best pattern.
They have a pattern called a sub alpine
open country sub Alpine,
I think it's called,
but it's a,
it's just a bunch of dots and splotches.
The whole idea is just to break up your,
your outline.
So when someone looks at you or an
animal looks at you,
they don't know what the fuck they're
saying.
So the idea is that this heck suit
somehow or another,
it blocks out your electrical output.
Whatever that frequency is that these
animals can see and it's,
it's not proven.
It's a,
it's real weird stuff.
It's like we know that there's something
that gives off,
like these hex companies that they've,
um,
that one company,
they have this machine,
they'll show you,
that you wave your hand over this thing
without a heck suit on and it registers
this electrical frequency and then you
wave it with the hexagon and it
registers nothing.
But if they smell you,
you're still fucked.
But anyway,
these birds somehow or another,
they're all given off a frequency so
that when they're doing that crazy wave
and they're flying,
they're flying,
right?
So they're beating their wings together
like a bunch of fucking helicopters,
but they're not touching each other.
They're just floating back and forth
somehow.
And Somehow it works.
It's a,
it's got to be inches apart,
inches,
inches.
I mean there's these huge migrations of
birds that are flying through the air
and they moved,
like fish in the ocean,
the same sort of thing,
right?
And they say that's how fish do it too,
that they have this frequency that
they're all giving off.
And some somehow or another,
they all know how to move in tandem.
Like Nolan's fuck,
oh well we're going left and right.
Not Bad to each other.
There's no straggler either.
Like one guy off the fucking side.
It's weird.
I don't understand it,
but people are trying to capitalize on
whatever that is or high mask,
whatever frequency we give off.
So the idea is that we don't really
totally understand animal senses with.
They've done a bunch of tests on deere.
They know they're colorblind,
they don't see necessarily Greens and.
But they see shapes and the,
they see,
they just,
their real concern is movement and
outline the outline of a person who's
very recognizable movement is very
recognizable when they smell pretty
good,
but they don't smell nearly as good as
something like bear is apparently one of
the best at like using their nose.
Bear smell.
Anything like bears can smell a dead
animal.
Miles,
miles,
miles away.
Yeah.
No,
that would make me nervous if I saw a
dead animal and I was in bear country
yet.
But we're getting a fuck outta here.
Fuck Outta here.
My um,
you talking about smells.
So this made me think of this in
Baltimore.
All the street parking's parallel
parking.
There's no assigned parking spaces and
there's no driveway or anything and my
brother pulls out in front of this guy
space one,
and the guy's like,
that's my space.
He's like,
snipe spaces,
fucking public street.
I can parker.
He's like,
that's my space in the front of my
house.
He's like,
dude,
come on.
So that night,
assuming that guy breaks into his car,
bust his windows out,
takes shit out of his car or whatever.
And he's like,
okay.
And he had some deer piss from hunting.
Any fucking busted that guys when they
dumped it all in his vents and
everything,
I was like,
I car.
So they're taking turns breaking each
other's what ended after the deer piss
went in there,
that,
that was the last of that shit because
that stuff.
Do you ever use that?
Do you ever.
You don't ever put it on,
you know?
Yeah.
That stuff's supposed to it.
I couldn't the smell of it just sitting
on the sidewalk.
I was like,
good God.
Yeah.
I would think a deer would be like,
why is that though?
Pissing all verse of that crazy
potential.
I want to know if people really use it.
Yeah,
they do.
They use a cow estrus.
They have like a,
a smell of a cow.
Cow Bull.
Like A.
I'm not a cow bull,
a cow elk.
The put it on trees and shit.
Try to drag a bowl over because when,
when bulls are in,
when they're in the Rut and the females
are in heat,
when they come into estrus and the males
want to breed them,
apparently they just,
they just smell it and they go fucking
bananas and some people use that shit.
They'll put it on trees and stuff.
So that's what I wanted to ask you.
Is that more to mask our smell or is it
more to attract?
They're attracted to attracting them.
Yeah.
The way they mask our smell,
their sense of smell is so powerful that
it's almost impossible to mask it unless
you use ozone and so would a lot of guys
do.
There's a company called Oh,
Xanax,
and what they do is they'll literally
hang a unit above their head and it
blows ozone gas all over your body and
it collects like your scent gets
combined with the ozone and that hits
the deer and the deer doesn't know what
the fuck you are.
It's like,
what is that smell?
It just,
if you ever smelled ozone,
you know what?
No,
I have no idea.
I'll turn on my tank,
my,
My,
um,
flotation tank,
and you could smell it because they use
ozone to clean the water,
to purify everything.
It's got a very distinct smell.
And when you turn the tank filtration
system on,
you're not supposed to go in it for half
an hour and the ozone disappears.
Dissipates.
But it's got a very distinct smell.
And apparently that smell just
overwhelms the smell of human body.
So when guys sit under a tree stand,
like I've,
I've hunted with my friend John Dudley
and Iowa,
and he uses this Ozon ics unit above us.
He sets it out there on the tree above
us and turns it on.
And it blows ozone over you.
While you're sitting in a tree,
so even if a deer downwind of you,
they might not bolt because the smell is
confusing to them.
Like what is that fucking weird smell
like?
They don't know what it is.
Like if they smell you,
they're like,
oh,
that's the dude got to go out.
Yeah,
like just a whiff that the wind will
change.
Like you know,
most of the times the wind's blowing
east,
right?
But then a little bit west,
a little bit of West.
They like the fuck.
They don't take any chances.
They just run.
But if they smelled that ozone stuff,
they're like,
what?
What is this fuck?
Is this?
I don't know.
I just run.
Take a chance.
Sometimes they just stand
there when they're horny.
They don't know what their debts.
Why,
why,
why people like the hunt them in the Rut
because when they're in the Rut,
they come out during the day.
Like a lot of times the older animals,
they become nocturnal.
They just decided it's too risky during
the day people are up.
I'll just just fuck around all night and
sleep during the day.
That's when I was always scared because
we would have a,
there's deer running all over Maryland
when you're driving those country roads
at night,
I mean three,
four of them will come out cross and in
Shit.
You're like,
holy fuck,
monster,
Monster.
Um,
so we had deer whistles,
know if they ever really worked to be
honest with her.
Yeah.
You put them in the front of your car
and then you don't hear it.
But apparently they hear it and it's
enough to.
But I had them on and it would still
come right up to the edge of the road
and shit.
Yeah,
they won the ruts going on.
They get confused.
They don't,
they're just horny and crazy.
They'll run right out in traffic.
It smashed by cars.
Deers.
That would hide all day long during any
other time of the year.
Just,
they just smelled that deer posting just
like,
Oh God.
I mean,
can you imagine that their nose is a
thousand times stronger than ours?
Oh fuck.
It is the smell of that posts.
It must be so tempting.
Run out in traffic in the middle of the
fucking thing.
For it,
yeah.
You know,
and you only got a couple of weeks to
fuck.
That's all right.
You know it not like they fuck all year
like us.
They got a couple of weeks to get there,
fuck on.
And then the rest of the year solo know
how weird is it?
Like what kind of a strange system did
nature come up with?
What makes the girls horny and able to
give birth only for a couple of like six
weeks.
Sometimes they go into estrus again,
like you have like a second,
a second estrus,
and then they all figure it out.
Yeah,
it's a male's song and you start
smelling fucking thinking less.
Apparently as good as they smell,
a bear smells hundreds of times stronger
than them.
They say a bear smells hundreds of times
better than a bloodhound does.
That blows my mind.
Great Miles blows my mind mile,
miles away.
When I drive from here and I get two
miles,
I'm going to be like,
God damn.
Yeah,
that's a long fucking way to smell.
So what they say is really scary is if
you're in places where bears know that
people hunt,
they hear a gunshot and they think it's
a dinner bill.
So like if you shoot a deer,
you only have a certain amount of time
to get that fucking deer out of there
before bear shows up.
Especially like Kodiak Island,
Kodiak island is famous for two things,
is famous for gigantic brown bears,
some of the biggest barriers in the
world.
It's also famous for Sitka blacktail
deer.
So these,
these sit deer are really delicious deer
and people go over there to hunt them.
But when that gunfire Supine,
that bear hears that as a group and they
go straight towards the sound of that
gunfire because they know there's going
to be a gut pile there soon.
So even if you miss
you gotta,
there's probably one coming your way.
Probably no shit.
So you gotta you bought.
You have to dress it out there too or
just got to get it and haul it out.
If you got it and leave the gut pile and
take the meat away,
you're likely to just.
The bare probably gonna go to the guts
and it's probably like,
you're probably going to be safe damn
keyword.
Probably.
Yeah.
I'm a fucking around the Kodiak bear,
my friend Steven Rinella,
who was talking about before they got
attacked last year,
they got on a fog,
neck island in Alaska.
They got attacked by a gigantic brown
bear and they said it was like 11 feet
long.
It was huge.
And one of the guys like it ran into
can't.
Well,
what happened was they had shot an elk
and they,
um,
you know,
when,
when you shoot an elk,
it's an enormous animal.
You can't really take it out all in one
trip.
You got to make several trips.
So they hung some of it up in a tree and
then they went back to get the rest of
it after they took what they took,
what they could carry,
they went back to get the rest of it.
When they went back to get the rest of
it,
a bear had already claimed it and they
didn't know the bear claim because the
bear took off.
I and heard them comment.
And then the bear when they were hanging
around the meat,
the was like fuck this,
and decided just to make a run out
though,
but didn't know how many there were
because it's such thick brush.
And they said it was,
it happened so quickly like everybody
had this,
well if a bear comes,
I'm going to do this.
You know,
people have this idea.
It was like,
it happens so fast.
I'll,
I'll send you the podcast because it's
fascinating.
It's a two part podcast.
They did it over two parts where they,
they talked about the experience but
she's.
Nobody got hurt.
But one guy wound up actually writing
the bears that delay or loud into them
and one guy hit the bear with a trekking
sticks like mountain trekking stick hit
in the head.
And the other guy got knocked over and
was literally on the bears back for
several steps as it was running down the
hill.
And then he fell off of it and then the
bear took off.
That thing had momentum downhill coming
at them.
No,
I've seen this video.
They said it was so big,
like my friends who were there,
four of my friends were there.
They were saying that they could see the
teeth 10,
11 inches from their face gnashing as
the thing ran by 11 foot long.
When you're talking what,
1800 pounds.
So while they're gone on round trip one
disparate already claimed it,
got scared,
heard them come and then saw,
oh you're taking my shit.
And it was like,
fuck that.
And came back to the defendant.
Yeah.
So it didn't,
it didn't come by to chase him off.
It came to fight.
It just didn't know how many there were.
And there was like seven or eight guys I
think at least I think one,
two,
three.
At least five guys.
And so I think it just got confused that
there were so many people and didn't
know where to go or what to do and then
it got hit in the head with a tracking
sticks and then you know,
fucking bag.
But like one of my friends had,
my friend remy had a pistol just for
that,
just for bears,
but he had said is packed down and he
like,
in his mind he thought,
well if a bear comes I'll be able to get
to my pack.
Fuck that.
He's like,
it happens so fast.
There's no getting to your pack.
There's no nothing.
And these are guys that know what fuck
they're doing.
They're professionals
with plans in place.
They're out in the woods hundreds of
days a year.
We're so weak were so we're like just
water balloons for a fellow man.
We're just,
we're nothing.
These things are like when you watch
them fight each other and they're biting
each other's faces and shaking each
other back and forth,
and it still doesn't hurt them.
Yeah.
That's,
we're,
we're so fleshy.
That's good.
We live here.
Let's good.
We live in Los Angeles.
No,
not in the fucking mountains.
No.
Maryland has a.
You guys have mountain lions,
right?
We have mountain lions.
But I saw I went hiking it from in here
one time.
I hiked it for awhile and I lived in the
valley.
I hiked there a lot and I would see a
lot of rattlesnakes.
I was solved a lot of rattle snakes,
but one night,
I don't know,
it's probably fall.
It's right around six,
6:30 and the sun starting to set and I'm
just trying to get through and I've got
my headphones on.
I'm coming down this hill and this
fucking bobcat comes off the hill and
it.
I mean this thing was the size of a big
dog,
stubby little tail.
It stopped writing.
I mean I was like,
Huh,
you know,
and it just stopped.
It fucking looked at me and the first
and only thought that went through my
head because I had nothing.
No,
what do I got to.
I was like,
maybe I can take my headphones,
choking
a little apple.
And it looked at me like it's your lucky
day in and it ran over the next Ridge
and was gone and my.
I mean I,
it's like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I've seen one of those with its babies.
Yeah,
they're cool looking.
They're big.
They're bigger than I thought.
Way bigger than what I thought when I
saw it.
I saw it,
I thought it was a mountain lion.
Yeah.
I was like,
look at that thing.
And they're like,
no,
it's a bobcat.
I was like,
what?
Oh yeah.
That thing was big,
like 50 pounds.
Yeah.
I thought,
you know,
maybe between like a little bigger than
a cat now.
This thing was like waste.
It was like up to my waist to the fuck
you out.
I was like,
I'm dead.
I'm fucking dead.
Have you ever heard a links?
How?
Only because that's the only reason I've
ever heard it.
Yeah.
Videos.
Crazy.
Right?
But they're facing right
now.
Well,
there was one that got into some guy's
house and the guy made a video of the
thing in his house,
Holland and I was playing it for people
like,
oh,
that's like sound effects,
right?
I go,
no,
no.
That's what it's really making this
noise.
It's really making like why it's in his
kitchen and it's gone.
Put it up.
This
what
it sounds like.
It sounds like little kids pretending to
be a month
who runs into this.
They get closer to the two.
They don't quite do anything.
Like neither one of them's
gangster.
They're both posers.
Ooh.
Headbutts.
And one of them almost swatted and was
like,
bitch,
don't make maybe slap.
Slap you.
Yeah.
That's a big animal.
Links are weird.
That's a weird animal.
Foods kitchen.
Yeah.
See if you can find the one with the
links is in the kitchen because this
fucking guy standing over it.
It's only like five feet away from him
and it's like,
I would say that's a battle cry.
You know,
I'm getting the fuck out of my own
kitchen or it's sick like this.
Here it is.
Here it is through this.
No
problem.
We find this guy's phone later covered
in blood playback.
His last video.
Exempt.
Scared.
Like I'm scared of snakes.
My brother gave me a fear of fucking
snakes.
My.
I have a twin brother.
He's four minutes older than me,
but we looked nothing like tall and
skinny,
but I will say,
yeah,
that's weird.
It's weird,
but there are times when we speak even
now and I'm like,
oh,
I just hit like it's his voice came out
of me.
It's weird.
That's the.
That's the weird thing,
but he quit,
he gets hurt and you feel it now.
I don't feel any.
We used to,
we used to fuck with like if there was a
girl in high school and I'm like,
I don't just talk to her.
I want to play video games.
He would set dates up and shit,
you know,
like going to the movies,
the ball.
I'm like,
God damn it.
But uh,
he was Mr outdoors like he wasn't,
he would play with snakes and he catched
black snakes all the time.
We'd put them in an aquarium.
We go the,
the pet store and get little feed mice
and you know,
they won't eat it when it's dead.
Sometimes they'd be dead.
So my brother would reach in and just
dance the tail and these snakes would
bite him in the fucking hand and I'll be
like,
Jesus Christ.
And he wouldn't even.
He just keep looking at the snake and
rub his handling.
You're fucking nuts dude.
So one day,
um,
it's my turn to cut the grass,
right?
We had the same snapper riding mower
from.
Can't buy me love.
Okay.
That snapper with a bad catcher on the
back.
Okay.
I'm in the backyard going around three
doors.
Ups.
Our Buddy Jeff lives there and I see him
and my brother,
there's a pine tree and I see him with a
broom and they're standing away from it,
but their swat and with a trash can.
I'm like,
oh,
they got a big ass,
big ass black snake in there,
you know,
so I've got my headphones on.
I'm just going around.
I look up on our deck and my brothers
stand there holding this fucking snake.
Exactly.
He's going to throw it.
I'm like,
don't fucking do it then.
Don't fucking do it.
I got my shirt off.
It's hot as summer.
I'm,
I go back to mine and business.
I come
back around a few times later and I just
feel something slapped the back of my
neck
and I look over,
this steak is looking at me.
I fuck.
I said,
I scream like a bitch.
I grabbed it.
I throw it on the fucking ground.
My brother's like,
don't.
I'll put that blade down,
dump that bag out.
I said,
there's your fucking snake.
You son of a bitch,
he would do shit like he catch the
little ones,
I can't remember.
Or they garner gardener snakes.
Maybe guard just a tiny ones.
I think they're called Gardner,
right?
Yeah.
I,
I don't remember.
But were garden snakes,
guarder,
steezy.
Those little slippery guys,
you know.
And we're uh,
my,
I'll never forget this.
We had a Volkswagen bug.
He and I are sitting in the back.
My little brother's upfront,
my mom's taking him into the doctor and
she was like,
you two can stay in the car.
Wait here if you want.
I'm like,
all right.
We drive them for like 10 minutes.
My brother reaches in his pocket and he
pulls out one of those snakes.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you?
How long has that been in there?
He's like,
oh,
picked it up.
I'm like,
what is your fucking problem?
Dude?
I was always scared around him with that
shit.
He would always like,
he thinks he is.
He thinks he's like that
he should go to Florida and try to help
those people out in the everglades.
You know,
they're hiring people to just shoot at
them.
Now.
They hired hunters to go names.
Yeah.
They have so many pythons.
All these crazy dirty white people who
wanted to own a python and the mother's
like,
you get that thing out of the house.
They just open up the backdoor,
chuck it in the yard and it slithers off
into the swamps of Florida is all filled
with swamps and the pythons thrive
there.
Come on.
I didn't know that it.
No,
no,
dude,
there's a giant problem with python
because of man.
Again,
we get this easy money not for python
hunters who grappled with everglades
giants for $8 and ten cents an hour.
Fucking they're so big dude.
They found one of them that had eaten an
alligator and the alligator was popping
out of his body.
They were both dead.
They were both dead,
floating in the water,
but this fucking eight foot alligator
was inside this pythons body.
Jesus Christ.
Look at this one,
144 pound reptile up on a levy.
They dispatched it with a nine
millimeter pistol shot to the head.
Inside.
They found 70 or 80 eggs.
See their fucking.
There's a plague of um,
the everglades.
There's so many layers.
It says it.
Yeah.
More than 800 caught this year,
this year,
six months into the year.
And what may be the most successful
program ever aimed at this huge
constrictors that are killing the
everglades.
Mammals.
Wading birds and alligators and
alligators.
Motherfucker.
Alligator.
Yeah.
They have python catching contest.
They track them with dogs.
They're doing everything they can,
but the,
um,
you know,
they're not putting a dent in them.
There's so many of them out there.
Man.
I used to the
watch the gator one word.
They chewed them and oh yeah,
swamp people on people because at first
they were extinct and then they dialed
that back now like,
oh fuck,
now they're overrunning shit.
Go and get them.
Well,
I used to live in Florida when they were
going extinct.
What does this one dear?
It was a deer that was inside.
Look at what?
Look at the size of the idea.
That's a big deer and it's inside this
python a
Jesus Christ.
That's funny.
We have people who don't have jobs,
who have day jobs,
people have night jobs,
some people have computer jobs,
technical jobs,
and they're all hunters,
herpetologists,
military veterans.
All these people are doing this,
going into the everglades,
trying to solve this problem.
They're saying adventure and a desire to
defend the everglades.
What thrills me is the fight,
the fight that the snake gives you that
maybe one day you won't when you're
definitely,
you're not going to bat a thousand at
that job.
I mean,
they're capable of killing people for
sure.
When they get that big where they can
swallow a deer.
I mean a deer's hunger.
That's a small deer.
I mean,
it's not big like a giant mule deer.
Anything like if you have that one that
they caught,
what in the.
I mean that's
five grown men a good distance apart and
there's still some
bows in that thing.
It's 130,
two pounds,
17 feet long.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
That is a big fucking animals.
That is.
This is all just from assholes.
Assholes.
Just chucking them into the woods and
Glulam.
I'm done with it.
The thing bit me in the hand,
can't.
My mouth is open.
I can't get over that.
That is now a plague because of that.
Oh yeah.
I mean if you think they killed 800 of
them this year and they're not even
putting a dent.
Right?
How many are out there?
God Damn.
Yeah.
You know what else they found out?
Their Nile crocodiles there was shoot to
kill order on Nile crocodiles.
So some ass fuck Dick Wad let Nile
crocodiles loose and they think there
might be breeding populations of Nile
crocodiles,
those 28 years old,
the monsters heat willdabeast
with teeth like the size of our hands.
And two days ago this guy was doing a
baptist baptism and uh,
this dude in Ethiopia and as he's in the
middle of doing the baptism of fucking
crocodile lunges up out of the water and
snatches him in front of his whole
congregation and brought him under
crocodile jumps from Ethiopian Lake
Hills pastor during mass.
Pat,
God's got plans for me children.
Yeah,
no shit.
Fuck man.
Man.
I,
um,
I worked in a junk yard growing up.
My friend's dad had a junk yard out in
Mount Airy,
was called Mount airy auto wrecking.
And um,
there was one day where,
uh,
so we,
we would have our own yard car.
We're driving where we,
we were in charge were younger kids,
so he would,
blake,
you're going to go get all the aluminum,
you're going to basically clean up the
junk yard of all the loose aluminum.
We're gonna,
put it in,
these bins will melt it down.
Then they sell it off in like these
little trays,
you know.
And one day I hear this,
we had a bunch of feral cats but we
didn't any dogs.
And one day I hear this fucking like
growling or is her,
her and I look over and there's a
fucking rabid raccoon.
It had one solid white I one solid blue
eye and it's bouncing just up and down.
It's not charging us.
And we're like,
what the fuck?
We start throwing rocks and shit,
add it.
And then we're like,
maybe it's protecting babies.
We don't know what the fuck this thing's
due.
And so we go down to tell his dad and
his customers down there,
this is out in the country,
is customers down and he's like,
I got a pistol in my fucking car.
He brings this thing up to,
to the Dome to put it down to two.
Took one to the head and it.
And it just was like
laying down ground to,
to put this rabid,
raccoon,
rabid.
It was test.
Definitely,
yes.
Definitely read to.
Had to have the whatever animal control
come out and take it away and shit.
What does rabies coming from?
Like there has to be like.
I always thought that about VD who's
patient?
Zero dirty motherfuckers out there
giving.
Everybody said
what did you have to do to get gonorrhea
was the first person to go because it's
crazy that there's diseases that kill
people.
Like Al Capone.
He got killed by syphilis.
Killed by some shit that you get from
fucking.
Yeah,
let them eat him alive.
They let them do what they did.
That's what I've read before.
Like they couldn't get them on anything.
So they got him on tax evasion and then
when he developed syphilis they didn't
treat it.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And then he lost his mind.
You
just ate his brain away like crazy g's
home,
bro.
Did you know that syphilis was the
reason why all those dudes in the olden
days had powdered wigs?
No.
Yeah,
man,
I should come here for my education.
God Damn Goofy as education.
You miss out a lot of critical shit.
Like
I repeat it all the time.
We've.
We've covered this several times,
so I'll just be really brief.
There was a these royals from,
was it France?
Something like that.
Jamie will come to the store,
but they got syphilis and to cover their
syphilis,
they started wearing wigs and syphilis
was running rampant through this.
So all these rich people started wearing
wigs.
So these big ass wigs.
Can I ask you,
what was it eating their skin like?
Was it like a psoriasis and shit?
They use noticeable.
Yeah.
The hair falls out,
falls out a big patchy.
The reason they did it,
I thought it was all to be majestic and
became that.
It became that and the bigger the wig
though,
the more money you had,
like if you had a lot of money,
you get a big crazy wait.
That's why we call like rich people,
bigwigs.
Why do people wear powdered wigs like
those guys?
And it all came out of these two,
two brothers,
I think they were serious for nearly two
centuries.
Powdered wigs called parex were all the
rage that cheek chic hairpieces would
have become pop,
wouldn't,
would have never become popular.
However,
if it hadn't been for a venereal
disease,
a pair of self conscious kings and poor
hair hygiene,
the proof begins like many others with
syphilis,
by 1580,
the std had become one of the worst
epidemic is tried.
Eastern Europe was strike Europe rather
since the black plague.
And according to William,
close,
an infinite multitude of syphilis.
Patients Clog London hospitals and more
filtered each day without antibiotics.
Victim face the full brunt of the
disease,
open sores,
nasty rashes,
blindness,
dementia and patchy hair loss.
Baldness swept the land.
And so,
um,
these dudes Louis the 14th,
it was only 17 when his mom started
thinning,
worried about baldus would hurt his
reputation.
Louis hired 48 wig makers to save as
image.
Five years later,
the King of England,
Louise,
cousin Charles the second did the same
thing when his hair started to go gray.
Both men likely had syphilis.
Cordy Aes.
Is that how you say that,
cody?
I would go with that.
And other aristocrats immediately copied
the two kings.
They supported wigs and the style
trickled down to the upper middle class.
Your Europe's newest fad was born.
And that crazy.
It is.
See where it says there,
the,
the bill for large elaborate Peru
balloon to as high as 800 shillings.
That turn the word big wig was coined to
describe snobs who could afford big,
poofy Perutz.
So the average was 25 and they're paying
upwards of 800.
Yeah.
Look at these dudes.
They had like crazy wigs,
like who?
Those wigs shit.
All because of an STD.
Yeah.
They all were bald with fucking sores
and shit everywhere.
It looks like one on his feet flat on
his face.
Probably got a hole in his face.
Losing his teeth still still fucking was
still fogging up.
Semi getting a semi hard.
They're shooting.
They're poisoning into people
on an education here.
Oh,
imagined life before antibiotics.
I can't imagine life before like the
eighties.
People did shit.
Like when we were having a baby,
I thought about like,
how do people do this in the covered
wagon?
Like just going there.
Yeah.
They still do in bathtubs,
these assholes and rice fields.
I was reading these things about these
ladies that'll go out and rice field and
stand in the hold and they'll drop it
into the water.
I don't know if it goes in water,
but they just natural and squat and then
they'll just have it and have someone
there to catch it and fuck.
I was like,
Nah.
I think in Baltimore and mercy it's
called Mercy Hospital.
They were the first,
I'm pretty sure they pioneered the
underwater birth.
Like you can go get in a tub there,
a big tub,
and then they say,
I guess that's the most natural way to
have a baby.
I guess it makes sense if you're in a
placenta and you're just basically
transferring into another one before you
come out instead of just boom out.
But they say it's.
I don't know how it's natural.
I mean how can it be natural waters not
attached to it either.
What?
Breathe?
Well,
I think I don't know that quick and
bring it up.
Yeah,
and it's in like a tank and you sit.
She sits in there and then they just
deliver it in this big,
big water tank.
Like how's it kid breathing when they're
in the womb?
I don't,
I never thought about that.
Have literally never thought about that.
I know they're attached to the umbilical
cord.
Biblical cord.
They're in,
they're there.
They're all curled up in a fetal
position.
How they get in,
they're like,
what's it going through the court?
I,
I mean I think all life comes to the
issue.
The court.
So do they not have to breathe while
they're still attached to the court?
How does that work?
Here it goes.
The fetus is not actually breathing
will.
Mother breeds for the fetus and
essential oxygen is passed to the fetus
through the umbilical cord to the fetus
does not make breathing like movements,
though.
These began at nine weeks of pregnancy
and allow the fetus to practice this
breathing movement movement.
Fuck man,
that is just.
You know what's really weird?
You take a baby,
you chuck them in the water.
They immediately hold their breath.
They know exactly what to do,
but monkeys don't throw a monkey in the
water.
They fucking panic and start breathing
water and they die.
Really?
Chimps to now kick.
I can't get over the education.
We tell it to everybody.
All you know chinchillas drown in the
water.
You know Joe Rogan?
I did 100 of them.
They all ground 100 rounds.
This must have a peer review.
Yeah.
There's something about people like,
we know how to hold our breath even when
we're babies.
If someone takes a look like that
nirvana picture,
remember that baby?
That was a real baby swimming,
like kids love it as long as you do it
to them on an early age and you're there
to catch them,
oh,
this is horrible.
Don't watch this.
Don't show me this.
I don't want to see this fucking
baptism.
That slamming this baby into the water.
What races that were Greek Orthodox.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
That's crazy shit of what somebody said.
I think Sarah sent me that.
Like,
what is that?
Or babies in a pool and that popped up.
Let's end all this baby stuff.
That's how the horrible thing that they
do.
They smash that kid into the water and
pick them up by their arms and smash
them down in the water again and they do
it a bunch of times and then they cut
his dick.
Yeah.
Dick don't look pretty bro.
Nope.
Cut it up bro.
One day old Dick up,
man.
Slice,
slice and dice.
I was glad I didn't have a boy because
I,
you have.
You have two girls.
All girls.
Three girls.
If you had a boy,
what'd you get?
Circumcised?
See I,
I was glad I didn't have to make the
decision.
Yes,
stick me Catholic.
I am,
but I was like,
what?
I do that.
No way,
dude.
Sometimes they lose their Dick.
Sometimes it gets infected.
It happens every year,
every year to shot a little
circumcision.
Jobs year,
kids get infections from circumcisions
and they lose their Dick every year.
Also,
kids,
this has happened multiple times.
Kids have been circumcised by a
traditional,
you know,
what is it?
Oil with the rabbi and the rabbi's had
herpes and they've transferred it
because the rabbi has to suck the kids.
Dick stop the bleeding.
Yes.
They still do that.
They still do that and they still defend
it.
It's a traditional way of doing it and
you're giving it.
Herpes.
People have given the baby's herpes and
the kids have died from it.
She says,
yeah,
they've died from it.
Yeah,
I didn't know that.
Still gone down to they suck the baby
penis and there's a fucking video of
this one rabbi explaining the necessity
of doing this because it's the part of
the ancient book.
It's in the Torah,
wherever it is.
Robert Baker estimates 229 deaths per
year from circumcision in the United
States.
Ballinger estimates that approximately
119 infant boys die from circumcision
related each year in the U.
s one point three percent of all male
neonatal deaths from all causes are from
circumcision.
These are several cases.
There are several case reports of death
in the medical literature.
Yeah,
people die all the time from
circumcision or just understand that
folks,
this is an elected unnecessary surgery
that you're doing to a fucking baby and
there's no medical reason to do it,
but oh well.
Hey,
it's prevents people say stupid shit
like that.
It does.
No,
it does.
It doesn't make any sense.
There's a lot of people that are doing
it to justify the fact they've done it
forever and try to come up with wool
hygiene.
Wash your Dick,
you dirty bitch soap and water.
Wash your Dick.
I watched a guy at the gym one time as
the old Dube stood underneath.
You know the hand dryers?
What?
His balls?
Yeah,
he rolled his circumcised dick down to
dry.
I've never used that edge right here to
get out.
There's a fucking there move,
Dude.
That's it.
Doesn't have any shame.
Well,
I don't know if those numbers are
accurate that you just read or that we
just pulled up on another article
talking about it and this is an
Australian link to talk about the same
information that says that by or
according to this study that not all
deaths that might be circumstantial,
unrelated are officially recorded.
Oh,
there might be more.
So they hide it.
I guess they call it something else.
They say it's an infection or something
like that.
I mean,
man,
it's unnecessary.
It's barbaric.
They're going to look back on this 100
years,
500 years from now and they're gonna
make fun of it the same way.
We make fun of powder wigs,
but it's even worse because you do want
it to babies,
you know,
babies can eat,
didn't have any of you say by the time
they're adults.
They're like,
what happened to my Dick?
Exactly.
Like we just thought it was ugly.
We had you cut.
Cut.
Yeah,
I mean I would.
You should.
I mean,
you shouldn't be,
that's a decision a person should be
able to make because I feel like every
guy at the age where they were old
enough to make that would be like,
fuck,
I'm not doing that.
Do you just know that some guys are
trying to grow their circumstance?
Their forced back?
Yeah.
This is what they're doing.
They're taking the skin that they have
the regular skin around their dick and
they're stretching it out and there's
all these devices like the lip poll and
the poll shit.
They're trying to get it to go back so
they've taken like the base of their,
their Dick where it was cut and that
pulling skin up a little bit every day.
I'm not kidding that this like devices
that they have,
you pull your pants pull before
so they believe by when they can really
pull it.
It'll reattach and grow.
Will.
It looks weird.
It looks like a turtle neck.
I'd never really looked like.
You know,
it's not a single layer of skin.
At the top you've got a double layer.
Now it's gotTa.
You gotta rolled layer.
You do have skin at the top,
but it's like,
you know,
fucking.
It's like a blanket.
It's not like a sheet.
Right,
right.
I can't get.
I can't get over people doing,
I guess people do every day.
Why am I.
So there's a whole community of people
that are trying to grow their force,
came back,
they're really angry and they feel all
this pain and emotional pain from the
fact they cut their dick cut when
they're a little baby and they had no
say in it and apparently it makes your
Dick Dick less sensitive when you do
that and your Dick is naturally self
lubricating the head of your Dick is,
and as soon as they cut the skin off,
then it dries out and you know,
we're used to dry dick.
I was like,
alright,
I got plenty of that.
But apparently regular discs,
if you don't cut them,
they're moist.
The tip like you pull that force came
back and that tip has got like a layer
of mucus on which is why you got to
clean it and cut it off.
Jesus Christ.
That was man.
Yeah,
it's a weird practice,
man,
and it's.
It doesn't make any sense.
The fact that it's still around in this
day and age with all that we know and
all the risks that we know about where
kids actually do get sick and die from
it.
That's a real thing.
It happens every year.
Who knows how many people are out there
that have fucked up dicks that had just
because some asshole,
ancient tradition that we passed on.
You're just supposed to do it.
Yeah.
My friend did it to his kid.
He goes,
I don't want my kid to have a weird
looking dick.
Like,
what are you talking about?
New going to be looking at how are you
going to.
How are you trained that kid?
Do you really think that that's going to
fuck with them?
Like,
yeah,
he goes to the locker room and all the
kid's gonna Stare at his Dick.
I go,
what?
I've been in locker rooms,
a piece of shit.
Nobody cares.
Nobody.
Joey Diaz,
he calls his dick the Cuban egg roll.
He wasn't,
he wasn't circumcised.
I've seen dss,
Dick East at least a hundred times,
at least a hundred times and pull out a
stick for punchlines of jokes and um,
uh,
you know,
we're hanging around the parking lot or
something like that.
I've got pictures of him with his pants
down,
like carrying somebody on his shoulders
and his pants are down.
It doesn't have any underwear on.
And he says,
Dick,
he's so crazy.
But nobody was going hanging out with
you.
Hook for skin.
How come you didn't get cut,
right?
Yeah.
Like what kind of kids?
You know,
what kind of kids you're bringing your
kids around where they,
they're going to tease him.
We can't kid can't take a little
teasing.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm sorry.
My dictate and get mutilated by the
witch doctor.
That's the fucking.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Your Butcher Dick over there.
And this shit's fucking intact right
here.
What did it feel like when that oil was
sucking on your deck?
Yeah,
that's when you were two days old.
That's the,
that's the thing I didn't know was still
going on.
Now obviously,
do they circumcised babies still,
but I didn't know that.
Do they defend it and said it's an
Orthodox Jew tradition.
I wonder if he got his dick.
So when couldn't use
because it was hard.
They were keeping the game.
Yeah.
Alright.
Was deep in the game.
Are already went to Israel and lived on
it.
What is it,
a blitz or something like that.
One of those things.
He was in one of those colonies where
you're,
you know,
you're reading the Torah like fucking 10
hours a day
deep.
And he talked to me about that.
And you and it's a funded trip.
You pay nothing to go do that.
It's your um,
said,
I'm probably saying it,
but is it not right of passage or maybe
it is.
I don't know.
It's uh,
something that's paid for if you want to
go.
And he was telling us how he went there.
Yeah.
He's a fascinating guy because he went
the other way like they did and they got
him over there and after like he just
experienced it all.
I was like,
okay,
this is all horseshit.
Sure.
It was crazy braids.
Yeah.
He had all that stuff.
You had the crazy braids.
He went to Kennis and route.
Yeah.
But yeah,
without the head injury,
no kid isn't.
All that shit came from digital that,
that all came from a head injury.
Are you serious?
Kinisons book?
My brother bill or um,
my brother Sam,
um,
his brother Bill wrote a book about him
and he said that Sam was one way and it
like a normal kid,
like,
you know,
calm,
regular kid and he got hit by a car and
when he got hit by a car he was like,
like seriously injured bad head injury.
And then out of that he was a wild
motherfucker.
Oh,
it all changed.
That happens.
People head injuries.
I,
um,
I had a good friend of mine,
she passed away when she was 16 and I
was talking to the doctor at the time.
I'll never forget,
he said this about the soul and you knew
we were just having this conversation.
He said,
I believe the souls in the brain.
And I said,
why?
And he goes,
Everyone associates the soul with the
chest and the heart and the soul and the
heart and soul.
And he said,
but I can literally replace anything in
your body and you're still Joe Rogan,
but the moment,
the moment I even tweak your brain,
you can become a different Joe Rogan.
And he's like,
that's why I believe the true soul is in
the brain.
I was like,
that's really fucking interesting
because you can't manipulate a brain and
still,
well maybe you can,
but you start changing even a little
thing on a brain and it can be like you
just said,
become a wild man from that.
Or the other way.
You remember when you were a kid,
they had tvs that weren't that good back
then in like the TV didn't work good and
you'd fucking smacked that bitch.
It would work.
There
was something with people.
Some people you just fucking rattle
their cage and they become a different
thing and it works better,
but it's like a very inexact,
like people had gotten hit in the head
and all of a sudden been able to play
music and got really good at math.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So Gora talks about that on his special
with a head injury and comes back with,
Oh man,
is it tourette's or something?
They come back different yet accent.
That's what it was.
An accident or sudden accident.
Yeah,
right.
That's really cool.
Yeah,
Dude.
Head injuries there.
It's a weird thing.
The Dome is a weird thing,
you know,
with all the weird fucking shit going on
up there and all the different synapses
and neurons firing and one little,
you know,
rock the somebody throws at you boxing
the side of that.
Now you're a different person.
Yeah.
Forever.
Because there's so many stories about
that too.
I've talked to so many doctors and
neurologists that are,
you know,
they study the human brain and it's one
of the most perplexing things is like
you can get the same two people,
one person gets hit the same way,
nothing happens and the other person is
a different human being for the rest of
their life and they'll struggle with
that injury forever.
And it's like real similar,
real sick,
real similar impact.
Real similar circumstances.
And you just never know.
You never know what's going to do it.
That's why these was this.
The Czech dog and round British woman
wakes up with Chinese accent moment.
Oh,
play this,
play this.
I want to hear her.
Well.
It wasn't always the
sweet and sour chicken,
Hong Kong style.
There's just been such horrible thing to
go.
She was diagnosed with foreign actors.
Keep playing
their reports.
Others who have suffered from the same
change in voice had severe migraines.
Only 61 cases have been identified since
1941.
One explanation for the new tongue is
that her migraines,
which she experiences as many as 10
times or more per month,
are leaving her with neurological
damage.
The condition usually follows traumatic
brain injury or a stroke.
Those with fas also experienced loss of
vocabulary,
but
let me hear it again.
If he files be sweet and sour,
chicken,
Hong Kong style
to go with that is that.
That's her to welcome.
She doesn't have it there.
Let me hear it again.
She was very nice accent.
She literally will cut open.
Geminis wasn't no voice that came out of
nothing.
If he files be our ticket Hong Kong
style,
it's just been such horrible thing to go
with.
She was just having an idea that's not a
Chinese accent.
That's the broken English exit with a
Chinese,
uh,
from a Chinese person at why they giving
her of all things food or
have said anything like that.
They gave her a food or
order Chinese
sweet and sour.
I don't know if we can understand you in
else with the Chinese
assets.
Let's say this.
I mean,
that is kind of hilarious.
Like why play that play?
This one right here was this lady got.
She's got a British just as a Houston
Mama at the British.
What happened to her that she hit in the
head at the Queen's Tomfoolery?
Well,
the surgery I'm having my mom at that
accident,
Lisa Alameda from England,
sorry,
is 100 percent.
Texas
people who don't know me that,
hey,
where are you from?
Oh wait,
where's that?
I'm like,
Oh,
you from here?
How'd you talk like that?
So that's when the whole story comes up.
Six months ago,
jaw surgery to fix an old changed Lisa
speech too.
At that she was playing around with me.
I thought she was joking with me,
but then she showed me that the doctor
had told her she was diagnosed with
foreign accent syndrome and she searched
it and then I was like,
oh Lord,
Houston Methodist,
hold up,
hold up.
Pause right here.
Here's the problem with that.
I can talk like this.
It doesn't mean that I talked like this,
so if I come back,
like say if I got an operation,
I wanted to get a root canal and I came
back and I started talking like this,
but I've come to the Joe Rogan
experience.
People are like,
what's wrong with you?
I've diagnosed with foreign accent
syndrome.
Then we want you to talk like you know
how to talk.
No,
because I've been diagnosed.
I've been diagnosed with a disease.
I have an issue.
Please be more sensitive,
but I'm calling the news.
I'd like to get on the news today.
Please do.
I can't help it.
This is how I talk now.
Do you think they still possess the
original accent as well or is it just
that one?
Maybe that bitch is so dumb that I can
tap into and can't go back.
She says she's got one speed,
just knocked her into second gear and
she's trying to start off the line and
second.
Now all I have is,
what is this?
This woman says she's been described as
speaking in Italian,
French and even Japanese.
Oh,
she's crazy.
She likes attention.
Let's hear it.
Excellent Syndrome.
Cath joins us now along with Professor
Rosemary.
So 2006.
She was suffering from bad health for a
little while.
You'd had headaches and then you spoke
to your sister on the phone and noticed
that your voice was changing.
Yeah,
I started off with just the least and
um,
I was a good concern.
And I am with ill health.
I tend to get over fatigue.
So I fought it to start.
So Dutch still there.
The next wounding solely.
This list was getting a little bit
strange.
I run a stock on trends.
My role rose up there.
Left at that time I could speak.
I record a message.
Nobody back.
I thought,
okay,
nothing to worry.
Wednesday morning it was starting to go
like an alien by first year to go and
completely and then I lost my swallow at
the same time,
which that's terrifying.
So scary for my family.
They were still terrified for me,
but we'll stop.
Stuck me in.
Why are they scared?
Because you talking weird or because you
can't swallow.
He couldn't swallow.
Yeah,
she's the only spitting out.
Now I've been diagnosed as inability to
swallow.
Come on,
diagnosed and inability to swallow.
Plus I have a new accent.
All of a sudden this bucket with Canada
swallow how to show you the paperwork.
I've got a prescription for a cop syrup.
I want to cough swag,
but here's the thing then maybe.
I mean,
look,
some people are barely holding onto
reality.
You're right.
Barely need is one fucking smack.
Smack upside the head and all the
sudden,
oh,
that was sweet and hot toss off.
Tiny former beauty pageant has foreign
accent syndrome.
Okay.
Former beauty queen.
Let me hear it baby.
I'm terrible with accents.
Okay,
so some people were wondering where I
got my accent from.
It's really,
really crazy story.
Foreign accent syndrome is a rare
condition that only affects crazy
still speaking their native language.
Uh,
let me hear her this week.
Started off with listening to this.
She's never left the USA Turner.
What?
This was her accent.
Okay.
Hold on,
hold on.
Stop backup.
Backup.
Is that weed?
Sure.
Is Weed that is fucking weed.
That is a gigantic.
We'd plant behind this bitch.
She's high as fuck.
She's playing with these people.
She's playing with his people.
This lady's high.
She's barbecued terminal.
What your week is?
She got so high.
She thought she was British here
yesterday,
which is a September 17th,
2011.
I started having problems with my voice.
Oh my God.
I've got the same when I tried to talk
and say some things,
my tongue,
like it was right.
I had someone ask me about my ax and say
like,
just making a new video.
Um,
I had a headache for about three days.
Got Arrested in Logan's room and this
was in May of 2015.
And so they put me to sleep.
Observed me.
Pause this back.
This is nonsense.
This is like people think they're a Fox.
You can't.
You can't pick.
You can't stay in the one accent because
you don't know it.
No one can call people crazy anymore.
No one calls people crazy anymore.
You're not allowed to.
Oh,
you.
You are so rude.
You're insensitive to her condition may
be she's crazy.
May Be she's fucking crazy,
but if you think you're a Fox like Fox
can,
you know there's people that are Fox can
do you know about that?
No lot about furbies.
I love talking to you,
right?
Ken are people that really believe that
they're in the wrong life form,
that they should have been born at Fox,
specifically fox,
some of them foxes.
Some of them,
they,
they're UNICORNS.
I think there are all kinds of shit.
So what?
This is where it gets real tricky
because I think there's people that are
legitimately transgender,
like they were born in the wrong body.
Legitimately.
You agree?
Yeah,
I've met him.
Absolutely.
I believe it.
Yeah,
but I think there's also people that are
fucking crazy and they just decide that
they should have been born a woman or a
man or they go back and forth it.
What do we got here?
Other kin,
other Ken,
let's call it.
Oh,
here we go.
Think Demons.
Angels.
Elvin,
polymorphs.
Oh,
I'm a polymorph.
I've been thinking I'm a polymorph.
Thinking about,
um,
I want to be like one of those people in
Avatar.
I want to be the Navi,
Navi Kin,
the definition that fight
other kid.
What is the other kin are people who
identify as partially or entirely non
human at Dragon Alliance,
a Fox,
you name it.
There's probably someone out there feels
like they are more of these things in
they are human.
The other kin community can be found
lurking on Reddit,
tumbler TV tropes and other online
forums.
I believe it.
This poor people.
Look,
I think they get fucked up when their
kids.
Somebody probably cut the Dick when
they're a baby for all confused in
instant trauma.
I mean,
I have mental illness.
I have a cousin who is a paranoid
schizophrenia and my dad would tell me,
but he's my,
I don't remember how the fuck and second
remove shit works is my father's first
cousin.
Okay.
Still alive dude.
Smoked a carton of cigarettes in three
days.
I mean we have no idea how he's a throat
fucking left.
But he was really fucking.
He was a black belt in karate.
He was great at Lacrosse.
He had hopkins,
Syracuse,
big schools looking at him and then
he'll tell you he started doing drugs
and he went fucking the Syd Barrett
route and he just went off the fucking
deep end and he's permanent disability.
Diagnosed a paranoid schizophrenic and
um,
you know,
he's,
we all love him but,
and he's fucking hilarious.
Like he'll play with it because
sometimes he's on his meds and you can
tell you're like,
oh,
you're dialing in right now.
He'll start telling family secrets.
And I'm like,
don't listen to him.
Like not an option right now is when you
listen to them.
I can see it in your eyes the other
times when he's off looking over here
like fuck.
But we would go like,
he had an apartment and I would go visit
them from time to time and he had poetry
and sayings and stuff written all over
the wall and I'm like,
what is this?
And he's like,
well at night when I'm home alone,
the doctors come in through my window,
they drop liquid acid in my ears and
they knocked me out and then they
started taking samples of my body and
after they leave,
the love of my life comes and I can't
communicate with her.
So this is how I communicate with,
are these are there for when she comes
in to speak for me.
And I'm like,
Oh
yeah.
So his windows are nailed.
Shut to keep the doctors out,
Mike,
how's that work?
And he's like,
it's not.
So one day I'm over there and he's
watching TV with the volume all the way
down and the radio up and that's how
he's watching this program.
And I'm telling you,
it started to fucking make sense.
And I was like,
I gotta get the fuck out.
I gotta get Outta here.
I'm Outta here on the.
There's a disease that,
I'm trying to remember the name of it,
but it.
It basically is when people are around
schizophrenia looks for too long.
They develop schizophrenia themselves.
Really?
Yeah.
There's some people who are sympathetic
to it,
to the point where,
God,
I want to say,
I want to say it's called Allah phrenia.
There's a some sort of a disease that
occasionally infects people or gets
people that visit people in the hospital
that are schizophrenia,
so someone will come,
like family member will come visit you
and they will get diagnosed and they
will get admitted themselves and now
they'll actually get it.
I don't know to what stage,
but apparently it isn't.
It's a potential issue for some people
because like,
look,
have you ever been hypnotized?
No.
I thought it was horse shit to my friend
Vinny shoreman who is a sports
hypnotists worse with a lot of fighters.
He hypnotized me.
I'm like,
Whoa,
this is real.
It just puts you in a very bizarre
staff.
Feel that date.
Yes,
you're there,
you're awake,
you're conscious,
but you're in a strange state.
It's almost feel something.
Yeah.
I like.
You're like,
like you're in a tube of consciousness
or something like you're in a womb.
It's very,
very interesting,
but I'm listening to him and he's a
friend.
I trust him.
He's a great guy.
So it wasn't weird about it,
so I was like,
Oh yeah,
you could do it.
Good.
Let's see.
Let's see what happens.
I was Kinda skeptical.
It's like,
this is horse shit,
but I've been to.
Have you ever been to one of those
hypnotists comedy shows?
No.
My friend Frank Santos,
he was a guy who,
uh,
he's passed away,
but he was a big time comedy hypnotist,
guy in Boston and in Rhode Island and he
had a show and he,
I saw his show man.
He used to do like one night a week at
stitches and one night a week at Nick's
comedy stop.
And Dude,
we would go down there on days off just
to watch.
It was crazy.
He would take people out of the
audience,
like who wants to be able to tie.
And he had a weird way of talking who
wants to be able to,
you want to be hypnotized con.
It was like a around jolly fellow real
friendly glasses,
you know,
like totally unassuming.
You didn't think you'd.
And then he would bring these people on
stage and he would just be able to take
sweetie,
you're going to go under.
You're gonna,
you're gonna fall asleep.
You're gonna fall asleep.
When I snap my fingers,
you're going to thank you.
Or Sally fields have right next to you
is burt reynolds
and you would see these people and they
really.
They were like smokey.
We got to get away from the police.
Like they really believed.
He had this one guy.
He told her.
He me what day would actually
speak like that person.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They didn't know what they were out of.
This one guy,
he told the guy this was the eighties.
He told the guy that the guy was having
sex with Madonna.
He's like underneath you as Madonna and
you're squeezing her booties,
your Boobie,
her boobies,
and she's naked and you're about to have
sex with her.
You're going to have sex.
You're having sex with her right now,
and the guy had an orgasm on the stage.
He's,
he's sitting there on the stage,
he's like,
oh,
and the audience,
I'm talking,
people have fallen out of their fucking
chairs.
The crying,
laughing,
you couldn't,
but it was real man and some people,
it wasn't real.
Like some people would look at him and
he go,
hey,
hey buddy,
look at me,
look at me.
You're not under good.
Come on and come off the stage.
I was like,
ah.
And the guy would come up to say he
would know who was under who wasn't
under this guy was a.
He would work with people who were
trying to quit smoking and trying to
quit gambling.
A friend that did the smoking thing,
gambling booze.
They can apparently they can do it with
a lot of different things with him,
but smoking is a big one,
but he,
he just could do it to some people and
I'm telling you quick,
he would do it and there's fucking 300
people in the room,
but he would be like,
I'm going to cut my fingers from the
count of three.
You're in the car and the police are
chasing you.
One,
two,
three.
What are you doing now?
I'm in the car and the cops are chasing
me and it was just instant man.
I mean it was.
It was.
Some people,
they just fall into these states of mind
and they're open to suggestion.
Some people can be hypnotized and this
is why some people I think join cults,
like I'm watching this new netflix
program,
wild wild country,
fuck crazy.
But some people I think are more
susceptible to suggestion and more
susceptible to colds and I think that
is,
that's what's happening.
I think that's what's happening with
this Allah phrenia thing,
if that's what it's called,
I'm.
I might be remembering that incorrectly,
but this,
this thing that you've been around a
schizophrenia person,
like whatever weird error,
their brain is making your.
Your brain tunes into that error and you
start going crazy too.
As soon as that shit made sense,
I was like,
I gotta get the fuck out of here because
he's done.
He's harmed.
He's never heard anyone but he still,
you know,
these days he's white.
He's pro guys probably in his sixties,
not in any kind of shape,
but back then when he still knew of
martial arts,
he was dangerous,
but he never hurt anybody but he knew
how to and so one day there's eastern
avenue in Baltimore's,
for lack of a better term,
the Ventura Boulevard of Baltimore shops
everywhere and everything.
And there was this one woman that had
cut his hair one time and for him,
excuse me to touch his head,
was a big deal for him this.
So he immediately fell in love with this
lady.
Her name was Clarissa.
So he went home and got his guitar and
the thing about this guitar,
like this dude would pawn his bed,
his guitar,
everything.
But that guitar was always out of tune
exactly the same way.
You understand what I'm saying?
Does that make sense?
Okay.
So always fucked up,
but always consistently fucked up every
guitar he had.
That's how he tuned it.
That's how he heard it.
Oh Wow.
So he writes her that he writes her a
love song and he wants to go up to her
shop and now sing it for her.
So he goes up and he stands out in front
of the shop and he's gets her attention.
He's got his guitar and he's gone.
It starts off where he goes.
He goes,
Chris,
I love you in Baltimore accidents.
Her name's Clarissa.
But he says,
Chris,
Okay Chris,
I love you Chris.
I need you.
Then he goes,
chrystal,
daggers of Christian,
all crack because I want to crystal.
And she's freaking out like,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
like your eyes.
So they call the police,
he gets arrested.
He doesn't understand why he's arrested
in his mind.
What did I do wrong?
I just wrote a beautiful song for
someone I care about and I wanted to
share it with her.
So my cousins,
all of us were like,
we gotta go to court and watch this.
This is going to offend because he's
got,
he's got to go to court.
So they bring them out from the back and
he stands up and it's a,
it's a female judge.
And um,
my,
his mom,
my aunt Margaret,
she's my great aunt.
My grandma's sister buys extended family
big time and we're all there watching.
And the judge says,
ask the girl her side of things.
It's like,
well this happened and he's like,
she's like,
would you like to speak on your behalf?
And he's like,
I just don't understand what I did
wrong.
I wrote a song for someone I care about
and I just wanted to share it.
And she's like,
would you mind sharing some of the
lyrics?
And we're all like,
oh shit.
And He fucking Chris,
I love you Chris.
I need you chrysotile crack because I
want to die.
She goes,
okay,
that's enough.
That's enough.
And then they're about to let him go
because they understand I'm going to put
a restraining order.
He's under supervision,
but they're about to let them go.
And she goes,
oh,
wait a second.
Oh,
there's a,
there's still an open charge here on the
books so we're going to have to take you
back to it.
He starts losing his shit.
Like what my Mr. greet stands up and to
a judge.
She goes,
Hun,
we dropped those charges.
Everyone calls,
people hunt in Baltimore.
She goes,
Hun,
we dropped the destroyed.
That lady said,
first of all,
you don't call me honey.
I am a judge.
You address me as your honor.
We're all like already got gold and they
fucking took him back and he was
screaming,
going on.
They put the family,
put a charge on him.
Yeah,
he had.
He would do things like he would show up
to their place in a cab demand.
They pay for it.
They didn't.
He throw a brick through the window so
they had
a resident for that.
Jesus really did drop the charges,
but it was just a clerical error that
never made it to the paperwork.
And she's like,
I got to do what I gotta do.
We're taking you back today.
And he was,
they were pulling it back and he was
going nuts.
Oh my God,
yes.
Ended up fucking haircut.
He would say shit and he would swear to
me that nurses would give him head in
the hospital.
He would,
and part of the time they're like,
I don't know,
but one that really blew my mind was um,
he had this scab on his stomach and he
was like,
they coming in and cut me and tested me
and they're taking me to the doctor
today,
Ryan,
I think I got something.
I think I got a disease and that,
that cut.
I'm like,
what are you going to do?
He's like,
I got a plan.
So I talked to him later that day and I
was like,
what did you do about that disease,
man?
He goes,
you know what I did with that scab?
I picked it off and throw it away.
He thought the scab
and you can just flick it away and be
like,
that shit's gone.
We're now imagine that's where he gets
that talk about people like it's not
funny.
Melted and it's not.
Mental illness is obviously funny,
but the shit he would do,
we would take him.
So it'd be me and my two brothers,
his daughter in Tucson's on Christmas
Eve,
we'd go over,
we take them a plate of food.
We'd hang out with them for a little
while and Shit and there'll be times
where he's like,
you guys got a joint,
like we shouldn't be smoking,
so we give them a joint and he smokes it
and now we're driving back to my aunt's
in the city,
which is 12 minutes away.
We get back.
What are you all given him?
We Hebrew.
He would rat us out.
He
came over and gave it a food.
Thanks.
By the way,
they gave you a big fat joint.
So then we would play it at why you
listen to his crazy ass.
Nobody gave him like we all had to be
able to say Tiki.
Oh,
he would.
He.
He smokes.
He would come to my grandma's house.
When I live with her,
he'd sit in a chair and he smoked
cigarettes like this.
I mean,
he doesn't put any farther away than
three by three inches from his mouth and
not just down.
Done,
down,
done.
And he'll do.
He'll go through three packs.
My,
his mom died of breast cancer and she
would say all the time,
I don't know how he even has a fucking
throat left and I'm dying of cancer over
here and he is.
He's still alive.
Still alive.
Smoking cigarettes like that to still
smoking cigarettes or a carton in three
days.
What does a carton?
I don't even know.
Twenty packs.
That's roughly seven packs a day.
Something like
a day for.
For decades.
Oh my God.
That is so crazy.
Now.
What?
Do you remember what he was like before?
Okay.
Phrenic.
I don't because when I was a kid he was
already gone,
but my dad loved them and would bring
them out to the house because he was
safe.
He was just crazy.
He would say shit and he'd be like,
don't you know,
don't give them a break.
Yeah,
don't forget to write and be nice.
Don't give them a bug.
A Brit.
But my dad will tell me all the time.
He was a phenomenal athlete.
Like I said,
great at karate.
He had a black belt.
He was cross.
No,
just a sweat.
He tried to tell me,
so highland town is the area where,
uh,
my aunt never,
this is the old Greek town in Baltimore.
It's not,
it's,
you know,
Greek as long gone in that neighborhood,
but that's where he grew up and he would
try to tell me that highland town was
the Haight Ashbury in Baltimore.
I was like,
get the fuck out of here with that
garbage.
But he was doing acid,
you know,
early 11.
And he dabble.
I think he said that early and then
eventually after like into the college
years,
the twenties,
he really
fucking ramped it up and he was almost
100 percent.
He made himself crazy story.
The common story is people that have a
tendency to schizophrenia or they may be
the likelihood of developing it later in
their life.
Acid trips,
mushroom trips,
heavy.
Psychedelics tend to bring out
schizophrenia.
They tend to make it manifest.
So maybe he was ripe for it because
there's no other mental illness in the
family.
It's just him.
Just him.
Yeah,
man.
I think especially when you're young,
you know,
I mean,
think about how many people have had
horrible,
horrible acid trips just taken way too
much and tried to fight it and just been
fucked up for days and weeks and then
you still feel slippery.
You life feels weird.
Even after those trips.
I had a DMT trip one time that fucked me
up for a couple weeks,
like for a couple of weeks afterwards
I'd be driving my car to be thinking
there's going to be a car.
It's going to launch itself off the
fucking the the oncoming lane and fly
right into me.
I was thinking I had this image that was
going to be upside down in the.
The.
The car was going to hit the windshield,
flying upside down and down and just
slammed for weeks,
weeks,
weeks afterwards.
That's why I'm scared of that shit.
It's because I tried to think about what
was possibly happening.
I think it dissolved my ego so much and
it made me think so much about how
relatively unimportant every single
person is in terms of the greater scheme
of the universe that whatever it did to
me had broke down all my conceptions of
myself,
all my preconceived notions of myself so
much that my ego was freaking out so it
tried to invent danger,
so I would have to be more primal to
defend myself again,
look out and look out over there.
There's danger instead of me going,
man,
what the fuck is life?
What is this?
What is.
What is the energy that courses through
your body?
What is the purpose of the human race?
Like?
What are we moving towards?
Why are we so committed to innovation
and technology?
I all these crazy thoughts where I was
trying to figure out what the purpose of
the activities of the human race war
that it was so bizarrely different than
my normal pattern of thought that my
mind just started coming up with all
sorts of weird paranoid ideas with
things.
It took me like two weeks before a
normalized and after two weeks I felt
nora and I didn't do dmt again for years
after that.
So here's.
Comedians have come on and talked about
it.
Is it?
Is it just.
I'm obviously asking you because I'm
ignorant is DMT,
isn't that the chemical?
Your body releases as you die,
your body releases you die,
but they don't really know.
They know that your body makes it.
They know that your liver makes in your
lungs,
make it,
and they think that your pineal gland
makes it,
which is your third eye and reptiles
that actually has a retina and a lens.
Really?
Yeah.
The pineal gland,
it sits in the center of your brain
literally die.
Like if you look at like a third and the
eastern mysticism,
that's where the pineal gland is,
and now they know that rats,
while they're alive,
produced dmt and the pineal gland.
This is a new study that was done.
I think this research was published over
the last five or six years,
so because of the fact that they know
that now they're assuming that human
beings also produce in the pineal gland,
which would,
you know,
it kind of sort of verifies what
everybody always thought the pineal
gland as they thought they would call
it,
the seed of the soul,
that this is where your,
your journey to the afterlife begins and
the pineal gland and that this chemical
gateway opens up and your soul passes
through to the great beyond,
but it can it be like a bad trip on the
way out?
Yes.
I've met.
I've been with people who've had bad dmt
trips.
I was his stan hope.
I got stan hope high on DMT and I
thought he was dying.
He's at,
he's at my house and he's.
He's moaning and foaming at the mouth.
He's like raw.
I'd never seen anybody do that before.
I'd see a bunch of people.
Most people smoke dmt.
They do this,
they smoke it,
and then they just go.
They lay back and then this,
this overwhelming experience happens to
them for like 15 minutes and then they
come back to it and then they come back.
Yeah.
They don't move.
They just,
that's not ours.
No,
no,
no.
It's a quick experience.
Iowasca is an orally active experience
with Dmt,
with Iowasca is when you,
if you tried to eat dmt,
dmt is broken down in your gut by
something called Mano Aiming Oxidase.
So when they make Iowasca,
what they do is they take part of one
plant which has dimethyltryptamine and
part of another plant which has
something called harming,
which is a dmp.
It's a mano aiming oxidase inhibitor.
Um,
Mao inhibitors,
there's some and medications and the sub
is a bunch of,
like you gotta be very careful if you're
taking mushrooms or something else that
you not taking Mao inhibitors as well.
But.
So you take this stuff together and what
it does is it gives you an orally active
dmt trip.
So as it's broken down by your gut,
it's like a slow release dmt trip that
will take several hours as opposed to
this fucking rocket ship ride to the
center of the universe that you get when
you take it,
when you smoke it,
because when you smoke it or intravenous
use,
if you go to a doctor and knows how to
do that,
that goes directly into your bloodstream
and it's just so.
It is impossible to avoid.
You cannot,
you can't hang on,
you're just going to take you to the
center of the universe and you're going
to experience life forms and interaction
with spirits and angels and aliens and
gestures.
For me,
it was a bunch of gestures that were
giving me the finger.
It was rate giving me the finger like
fuck you.
Like it was very,
very,
very powerful.
Um,
but that Stan hope one was the only time
I ever saw someone who I thought they
were going to die.
And I was thinking,
what if I killed one of my best friends?
Like,
what have I killed?
Stan hope I get you.
I was like,
I don't remember.
I think I did it first because I think
he had,
he hadn't done it before,
so I said,
I'll do it.
Just watch me do it and just sit down
here and then you do it next.
So I did it.
I'm gone.
Fifteen minutes,
come back.
I'm like,
you're ready.
He's like,
yeah.
So I give it to him and you know,
Stan hope's been drinking since he was
three.
His body is a loosely held together with
duct tape,
you know,
lies down if he lies down and pushes his
stomach out.
He's got these.
He's got these fucking.
What is it called?
Hemp.
No hemorrhoids.
What is it called?
Hurt.
He is.
He's got hernias.
Was his stomach,
will poke through the wall of his
stomach or his,
uh,
his gut will pop all of his abdomen.
He was,
he's got a bunch of those.
You got them all over the place.
Just like this little pop up,
like you're supposed to get those
up.
He just keeps on trucking.
And I've talked to him about this too.
He's like one of those no MRI guys.
Nah,
no doctors,
no Mris.
And I go,
I don't want to know what's going on in
there.
That's everyone did and my family,
by the way,
that's why I go to dog
and every so,
and this was more than 10 years ago.
This was probably 2002 while this was
all going down,
so me and stan hope or on my couch and
he is moaning like this,
some farms coming out of the corner of
his mouth and he's like,
slumped over and I'm just praying to.
I'm like,
please don't die.
Please don't.
Because I didn't expect this.
I expected what everybody else who I've
seen maybe a handful of people do dmt.
They all do the same thing.
They smoke it,
they laid back,
they tripped balls,
they come back in 15 minutes and they're
like,
what the fuck was that about?
But he was.
But then he came back and is like,
oh,
life eats life
cycle.
It's like,
it just goes on.
And so the next thing and then life goes
on and life is like,
Gosh,
I'm so far behind them so far behind
with my thinking.
I'm so far behind with everything
and I'm just like,
I'm just glad you're alive dude.
Yeah,
no shit.
I almost killed my cousin like that two
times.
I've watched people almost die on drugs
that I was with.
The one that scared me was my cousin.
We found out my cousin timmy is a.
he's allergic to.
It's got to be thc.
He's allergic to wheat.
It,
it just destroys.
I mean like that will fucking turn him
gray.
And so this is what I,
what we didn't know.
So his younger sister had had a,
she was turning 19 I think it was.
And I'm living with them at the time.
I,
my grandmother just passed away and I
don't have a place to stay.
And her sister,
my aunt Marie took me in and I'm living
with them and my cousin,
Jennifer's like,
I'm having a birthday party tonight.
The house,
the girls are all going to come back
here.
Right.
So my,
we get some good weed from Oregon.
It was rare to get good fucking bud from
the west coast in the early,
you
know,
the nineties regularly in.
You always got,
we call it a practice.
We'd as we always bugging got,
but this shit came and I rolled one.
Oh,
it was beautiful.
It just had a pencil point to a while.
We're smoking it and I was like,
let's.
It's February.
It's so fucking cold that,
that bone chilling cold.
I'm like,
let's go sit in my car and we'll smoke
this joint.
I had a 1990 Honda civic with original
rims,
Bro.
We're in their fucking smoking.
We're listening to Hendrix and he takes
one hit and he goes,
let me have a more.
I'm like,
you shouldn't.
And you remember that.
He's like,
let me have one.
I'm like,
this is really strong weeds.
I mean I have one more.
He hits one more,
so we get out of the car and he's like,
just standing up and he's got his hand.
He looks like he just stole second.
He's got his hands on his knees,
he's breathing heavy and shit is.
I'm like,
all right,
let's go get back inside.
And I'm walking down the driveway and I
remember visually seeing that gust of
wind come around the corner of the house
and just plan itself in my fucking
chest.
So I get the shakes.
It's like two degrees outside when we go
in the house and we're just start
throwing thermals and shit on.
And as I'm doing,
I'm looking at him and I'm like,
hey man,
you don't look.
You don't look so good dude.
He's like,
oh,
he's touching himself in the mirror.
He's turning gray,
start sweating.
We're.
He's like,
I don't fucking feel good.
I'm like,
go upstairs and get some water right
now.
And it progressed so quickly and he
looked like shit so bad that I'm over in
the mirror looking at myself.
Like I'm like,
I'm okay.
I'm fine.
I go out to come tell my cousin,
his sister what happens?
And there's a fireplace.
Fires going.
I'm sitting next to her and we're just
warming up.
And I'm like,
he goes,
what?
She goes,
what the fuck?
My brother over there.
I go,
we just went out in the car.
We got high and he's fucking freaking
out.
She goes,
well,
there's 19 girls here and 17 of us are
tripping on acid right now.
I go,
oh my God,
there's two girls.
Scared of the other groups were locked
in the bedroom.
He comes back down the stairs and he's
just.
He's battling for life at this boy.
He's tried to get in the bathroom.
They think it's the girls on acid so
they're not letting anyone and he just
turns around and at the time we're
watching.
I'm like,
look at him,
look at him now,
and he just takes two steps and he
stands erect and just rocks back and
goes face forward into the banister.
It cracks busted his face open.
He lays on the ground.
He starts having like a little seizure.
I'm like,
Oh my and I'm wearing you.
oh my God,
I just fucking killed him.
Friday had just come out.
My cousin on point jumps on top of them.
It's like,
you got knocked the fuck out.
They all start laughing.
I'm like this,
by the way,
my aunt and uncle,
they're asleep upstairs and I'm like,
oh my God,
his eyes are rolling back in his head.
This one girl grabs the fucking phone to
call nine slash 11.
She hits nine.
She hits one.
I'm already got his head tilted.
I'm ready to go.
I'm very good in controlled chaos and
I'm just.
I'm about to fucking put my mouth.
I can't believe I got to get my cousin
and they're all laughing.
They're on acid.
They don't.
They think it's hilarious.
I go to put were about and he
goes,
get the fuck off me.
And I was like.
I was like,
Oh God.
I go,
what the fuck happened was I was,
I was locked inside myself.
I heard everything you said couldn't
respond though.
I heard everything right.
I was stuck inside myself.
He had come out now his teeth or through
his lip here because he's hit the
banister and the chicks on acid now see
the blood and now they start freaking
the fuck out.
I'm like,
oh my God.
He's like,
you got to save it to the opposite.
17 girls have 19.
I'm like,
I'm not taking him to the hospital,
we can't go to the hospital and tell
them we've got a bunch of kids on and
on.
I was like,
you just got to suck it up and tough it
out.
So he waited until the morning and got
my uncle because it just busted his lip
all up and he was like,
I just tripped down into steps and hit
the banister,
but that was the second time that we
almost killed his ass.
He did a gravity bong one time out of
the kitchen sink.
I really thought he was going to die.
I'm like,
why would you ever touch weed again?
I was in New York film it fear factor
and I was with some friends that I don't
know if they get high and they
definitely don't get high on a regular
basis,
but we're all having a good time.
We're at a bar and it's post nine slash
11.
Right.
And so New York had a lively,
weird feel to it,
like a friendly feel to it.
It was very strange,
like after nine slash 11,
something happened in New York where it
was so devastated and horrible that in
the recovery process
people are nicer to each other.
It was very strange.
So anyway,
it was a friendly feeling.
So we're all sitting outside.
We're in this bar,
we're having a couple of drinks were,
you know,
it's right after filming,
I'm with the producers and a bunch of
the people that work on the show and we
go,
uh,
you know,
I go,
hey,
you guys want to get high?
And they go,
yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Okay,
so come on outside,
let's go.
And I'm giving them that serious
California.
We'd some serious California weed.
I don't remember what the name of it
was,
like whatever,
the jail break or whatever the fuck it
was called,
but it was,
it was really strong.
We all take a hit of this joint.
I take a hit,
I passed to my friend.
He takes a hit,
he passes it to this other guy and then
he passes it to my friend shy and she's
one of the producers on the show.
She takes a hit of it and her eyes
rolled back inside of her head and her
knees buckle and then she just goes,
and this,
where on the street she dropped,
dropped,
caught her.
I caught her just in time,
And um,
you know,
we,
we had to call the fire department,
you know,
we call nine slash 11.
The fire department came and they
checked her out and you know,
they could probably smell we a Myra if
somebody ran over a fucking scar.
And they were like,
hey man,
what are you doing?
I go,
yeah,
we're,
we're filming a fear factor here.
And uh,
you know,
she just,
she got dizzy.
He said,
oh,
she got dizzy,
Huh?
But just lucky we caught her man because
if we didn't catch her she was going to
bounce her head off the concrete.
I mean she just went limp.
She just went like this,
like our eyes went back and just went
like this and I think it was me and my
friend Tom Wind up catching her,
but it was um,
it was weird,
like her body just shut off or bodies
like too
much pot.
Fuck it.
Like her body was more comfortable going
unconscious than it was dealing with
being that high.
That quick,
tell me if you've ever heard this,
you'd be the person that asked.
So like,
I've never done acid coke.
I'm,
we'd,
I've done ecstasy a couple of times.
Not For me.
I've done shrooms a couple times where I
enjoyed it,
but after awhile I was like,
okay,
get the fuck outta here.
You know what I mean?
Like,
it's enough,
I get it.
But a friend of mine,
this was when I first moved out here,
we went and saw pink floyd at the Rose
Bowl and we take a bunch of weed and
some drinks and he's got a couple,
this guy and girl,
we're going to meet us there and she
brings shrooms and I'm just like,
I'm cool,
I'll pass.
But the three of them do the shrooms and
we're in the middle of the concert and
fuck the pigs are inflated their balance
and we're having a great fucking time.
And I looked to my left over here and I
looked back to my right and my friends
gone,
he's gone and I hear screams and I
looked
and I looked down and he's passed out.
Okay.
He's gone into a seizure.
So rose bowls,
the bleacher stadium seats.
So He.
What happened was he fell back and his
feet got locked up under the bleachers
in front of him.
So he's bent completely like this and
these fucking idiots behind him.
I shouldn't say fucking idiots.
I don't blame them.
They got scared instead of catching
them,
they moved out of the way.
So his head strikes the bleachers and he
starts going into a seizure.
And I'm like,
I've never seen anybody do this from
terms.
And they're all yelling,
is he epileptic?
I said,
I don't know anything.
The girl that gave them to him,
she saw it and she just immediately had
the.
She started vomiting in her like $45
concert shirts.
She just heard trip went south
immediately and I did not.
I didn't know what to do and I just
fucking punched,
punched the shit out of it.
It's in his face bro,
right across the jaw and he woke up and
he's like,
what the fuck happened?
I was like,
you just passed out and had a seizure.
He's like,
how long was I out?
It was like,
how long do you think you were out?
And he's like,
two minutes.
I was like,
is about 15 seconds dude.
And he's like,
Holy Shit.
And then he was fine after that,
but I've never seen that.
Yeah.
I don't know if the head striking the
bleachers what caused the seizure or.
But he just had this moment where he
just passed out from shrooms.
I've never seen that before.
It does happen.
People get knocked out and the seizure,
that does happen.
I've seen that before.
Their toes lockup up.
People get punched and knocked out the
toes,
lock up whole body like I know about the
arms that go up like this,
that this shit's dangerous.
This extended just extend.
It happens all the time and fights.
I have the weirdest thing,
this,
this make me laugh.
Just the weirdest thing I've ever seen
on weed,
you know,
smoking weed.
So I'm a Oreo Fan.
I'm a ravens fan.
And back in the day I'd go to Anaheim by
myself to see the orioles play the
angels and just nothing was built around
there.
Then it's a dirt lot.
I go by a scout ticket,
uh,
a single from this dude.
And then I'd go the street
to like $4 parking in were like,
it's a business complex,
like La dwp.
They're all in there,
but the buildings are in a square and
the parking's all in the middle and it's
just me and a friend of mine one time,
he's like,
hey,
he's a cubs fan.
He's like,
I know you're going to go to the game
today.
I love baseball.
You mind if I roll with you?
I'm like,
Nah man,
let's go do it together.
So we'd go out and it's early know it's
a 1:00 game.
So we're getting out there like 11 and
the two of us are sitting in the middle
of this empty parking lot of hundreds of
spaces were smoke.
We got sand chairs,
mogen joins,
drinking a little beer in the parking
lot,
tailgating before we go into the game,
like 150 yards down this corner,
this fucking pickup truck hops the curb.
And I mean like a hundred miles an hour
is gunning right at us.
That,
you know,
again,
with your friends,
it happened so quick.
We're like grip our chairs like the
fuck's going on and it,
you know,
those uh,
those cadillac commercials,
the on the dry lake beds,
but the mirage and it's humming right at
you.
That's what this fucking thing looks
like.
And it's a big ass truck and it pulls up
and it parks like,
just for spaces to our lift this
hundreds of spaces and we're looking at
you like,
what the fuck?
This lady gets out and she's like,
what's up?
What's up?
And she pops the tailgate down and it's
all happening so fast is obviously her
shit because she's just fluid doing
everything.
She grabs thing,
snaps it open,
it's a big ass wheelchair.
I'm like,
what the fuck is going on?
She goes over to the passenger door.
She opens the door up and she gets her
friend out who doesn't have legs and
we're like,
what the fuck is happening right now?
She sets her friend in the wheelchair
and she's like,
you guys got weed?
You got beer.
We got fucking Jello shots.
Let's do it.
We partied.
Our Lady.
I was so high.
I was like,
is there something to know out of
nowhere,
dude just decided to party with you.
We're pulling in here.
You're here,
we're here,
she doesn't have legs.
We're fucking doing this.
And we were like,
Holy Shit.
They had gel.
They were the nicest colon.
Everyone knew her.
You know,
she was a role.
They're like,
what's up?
She's sticking shit under her blankets.
I was like,
it's the weirdest shit.
I think I've ever seen what I've been
smoking for a water right there.
Well,
once you're partying is happening,
the normal rules of life kind of go out
the window.
The weird shit happens,
but I'm a guy.
I liked the story,
like I wasn't going to be like,
let's pack our shit up and get the fuck
out of here.
I was like,
let's stay here and party with these two
doesn't seem too dangerous to ladies.
One of them got no legs when they were
for cyber was.
She was a credit.
So that.
But what she told me,
she's like,
you got to Cherokee.
I go,
how'd you get in down there?
She goes,
you can hop the curb down there and
parked back here for free.
I did that for two more seasons.
All that off the tip of her.
Oh,
she just big enough.
She was right because she has a four
wheel drive.
Pop it right over the curb and go,
Shit.
Clever lady.
Yeah,
partying.
It's not good for you,
but it makes good God damn memories.
I remember it took me when I first
started,
I was a late bloomer on weed.
I was 21 when I started smoking.
I was 30.
Yeah.
You were like,
and I,
I.
It took me a month,
like I,
I was ignorant to the whole idea of just
having to learn how to smoke,
how to take smoke into my lungs,
you know,
just that you don't.
I didn't even dawn on me and I would
just be like,
oh,
just take it in.
I won't call for anything.
So it took like a month before I got
high and the first time I got high I
remember freaking the fuck out and I was
trying to talk myself through it.
Like,
it's a plant,
you can't overdose unless you smoke your
body weight.
At least I heard that one time.
I don't know if that's even a newborn.
Preemie can't do it.
I'm saying this shit to myself,
but I kept asking questions out loud
like you guys hear my heartbeat and I
was so scared.
I was like,
I'm dying and no one's
that.
Get me to the hospital.
It's got a fucked up guys.
They were like,
shut the fuck up.
Go downstairs dude.
You're brand new.
My step dad smoked weed and we stole it
once when I was in high school and me
and my girlfriend and my friend Josh
smoked pot over my girlfriend's house
and we were
16,
I think I was 16.
My girlfriend was 15 and we got so high
that we would wake up in the kitchen and
then wake up in the living room.
Like we would miss time.
We'd be missing spots.
Like how did we get here?
Like I never forget that.
Like when you're 16 you don't really get
paranoid because you're not worried too
much about stuff.
You too stupid.
Your brain has a fully formed yet,
you know,
and I didn't really understand pot.
I have no idea how much we smoked.
We just kept smoking it,
you know,
when you're 16 you don't know to stop,
you just keep smoking.
And I just remember like my whole body
was tingling and were like lying on the
couch together and we couldn't move or
like,
oh my God,
I can't move.
Then all of a sudden we were in the
kitchen stand in front of refrigerator.
Yeah.
Oh we were too high.
We just didn't know what we had no idea
what was happening.
That's the.
That's the one thing that's cool about
getting people that don't get high as
you get to see that overwhelming rush
where they don't really know what this
is or what to do.
Right.
Chris Mcguire,
I got him high once you know Chris?
No.
Standup comic.
Funny Guy.
He's produces a bunch of TV shows now.
He's one of the.
He produces,
I think he's the executive producer of
that.
Snoop Dogg and Martha Stewart.
Anyway,
got them high and he's like,
I think there's something else in his
body.
I think there's something else in it.
No,
no.
It's just.
That's what pots like today.
He's like,
no,
no.
This isn't pot.
Instant pot.
This is more than pot.
Like,
no,
this is pot.
This is what pot is now.
Pod is now a different thing.
It's like you go Italy,
you go back to some pot from the 19
sixties.
Those hippies,
they didn't know what the fuck.
There's no smoking bullshit.
Today's scientifically organized.
So my uncle,
he's in his eighties who's got stage
four cancer.
He's,
he's on his way out and he's not eating
at all,
so a couple of weeks now.
He hasn't had a bite to eat like two
weeks and my cousin takes care of him
and he's like,
I think in about giving them weed and
like give him,
we'd give it to him.
He's fucking 80 couple years old.
He's got stage.
What does it matter at this point?
Like heroin,
get whatever the fuck he wants to put
him at rest.
He's like,
I think I'm going to give him weed.
I'm like,
let them smoke some.
He used to smoke a pipe,
let them smoke a little bit.
So he goes down and he gives him some
weed and he smokes it.
And um,
he's like,
I'm just going to stay here with you for
a few hours and few hours go by.
He's like,
how do you feel?
Is like,
I don't really feel anything but I'm
tired.
I think I'm going to go to bed.
And the next day my cousin goes back to
see him with some more weed and he's
like,
how was last night?
He goes,
I didn't feel weird.
but I slept like a baby and he's like,
alright,
good,
let's,
let's try this again.
Day to not eating after almost two
weeks,
nothing smokes weed,
and he's sitting with them for a couple
of hours.
He's like,
how do you feel good,
you know,
I think I could ate and he ate a plate
of Spaghetti and meatballs,
heavy ass meatballs,
boom on day two from smoking marijuana.
And I was like,
keep going because Maryland's way
behind.
I think they finally just have their
first and only a legal dispensary and
he's the prime candidate for that shit.
You know what I mean?
I'm like,
go get him a prescription now and just
let him smoke himself on the way out.
That's one of the saddest things about
it being illegal and stigmatized for so
long.
The so many people with diseases and
arthritis,
inflammation,
all sorts of problems that had just been
just,
you know,
just told that they can't,
they can't have this one thing that's
going to give them relief and it's not
hurting anybody.
It's just a plant.
I got some cbd cream on my back right
now.
Phone works.
It's phenomenal.
That's stuff's amazing.
I can't even get over it.
No side effects.
I'm new to the CBD side of it and I'm
just like,
man,
it really fucking works.
Can I carry this shit with me?
Right in the fanny pack.
I got this liberty lotion,
this stuff right here.
Oh yeah.
I love that stuff.
I started using it when I was.
I had some tendinitis that's heel that
since,
but I had some tendonitis in my elbow
when I started using that and I was
like,
Ooh,
how many times a week?
Whenever you can use it,
whenever it doesn't hurt and the next
day you feel pretty quick.
You feel real quick.
I feel this pretty quickly.
Yeah.
I had a bit of a pulled muscle and the
outside of my hip and it was real stiff
and it was bothering me.
I put some in that shit on before I went
to bed.
I woke up in the morning.
I was like,
what did it go away?
It was weird.
I went to bed but it was aching and I
woke up in the morning.
Nothing.
Yeah,
just slather that stuff all up on there.
It just reduces inflammation.
I'm going to write that one down.
And here's the thing is one of my
sponsors here.
You can have that one.
Thank you.
Have that.
And here's the thing.
It doesn't,
it doesn't hurt anybody.
It's,
there's no,
there's no negative side effects.
Nothing.
High gang of that shit.
I got a bunch of those.
I wish I had more.
I love.
I mean I'm so new to.
I went and got this one that was um,
like super strings and man,
I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe I had a rough patch
on an elbow.
I was like,
I'm just going to say that shit was
calling it a day
that day.
Yeah.
It's great.
Well,
any sort of inflammation diseases,
like people that have like sore joints
and you know,
problems with muscles,
that stuff's amazing.
It just loosens you up and it doesn't
hurt you.
It doesn't fuck you up.
It doesn't get you high.
You feel exactly the same and some
people will take it orally.
I take it orally occasionally,
but most of the time I just rub it on
any part that's sore,
but when you take it orally,
like people,
they find that it relieves anxiety,
it helps them relax and it doesn't fuck
you up,
but you can drive.
It's not like you're high,
you're paranoid.
It just chills you out a little bit.
Just calms you down.
I just got a CBD vape pen.
I've tried the vape so the vape pens
don't work well for me.
The marijuana,
once I plant works well for my system.
Even edibles don't really.
I took two stars.
A death in front of Joey Diaz didn't do
a damn thing to you.
This fucking guy,
he.
He's.
He doesn't get.
Hi,
it's Jamie.
Jamie has one of those weird bodies
where he can eat like,
what's the most amount of edibles you've
ever eaten?
Thirteen hundred milligrams.
Jesus.
See,
that's what.
Here's what I feel like.
I feel like I would have to figure out
what that number is.
Go past that point and then dial it back
from there and I don't really want to go
past that fucking point,
you know,
1300 and saying I was trying to test to
see what a tip to.
But that's what I don't know that I did.
I'm sure I did a little bit.
Obviously I had to have like I did it
again.
I took a thousand and played video games
and like five hours in.
It was just,
it was really tough to play games.
I just like,
I didn't care,
I didn't want to sit there anymore so
it's hard to keep my attention on it.
So it obviously worked at some point but
it wasn't free.
I wasn't freaking out or anything.
Like you describe.
I can't take more than a hundred.
I go into the hundreds and I started
getting weirded out.
Like I like I'm a 25 to 50 milligram guy
because it gives me a little little
high.
Just get a little high and I'm fine.
Unless I want to go into the tank,
I'll go,
I'll take 100 and going in the tank,
but when I get in there and
lied to and I stopped thinking,
I literally start thinking about things
I did when I was 14.
Like why did I say that?
Why did I do that?
Like,
hey man,
forgive yourself.
You were 14.
Stop beating yourself up.
You're 40,
but I literally will think about stupid
shit that I did when I was a little kid.
It's,
it's so it just,
it forces you to examine anything in
your life that you might have pushed
aside,
like you have to come to grips and make
restitution and figure out what the fuck
you did that for and why did you have
those thoughts and why'd you behave that
way and you know,
how are you different now and how have
you grown past that?
That's the thing about marijuana that
it's really highlight.
It's a,
there's a lot of it.
People say it makes you paranoid and it
certainly does,
but I think a lot of what that is is
just making you aware of things you're
trying to.
Not think about it,
it's convenient for you in normal life
to not think about those things,
but as soon as you get high on marijuana
is like,
hey,
there's some shit that's bothering you
and you're not even thinking about it.
He'd come with me,
we go to the back of your head and I'm
going to shine a light on this.
Look at all this stuff.
What are you gonna do with that dress?
This motherfucker?
How much you clean this shit up?
Yeah,
those pens.
Do you like them?
Have you tried them?
I have,
I'm not a fan.
Um,
I,
I occasionally will use a pen,
but I prefer
smoking joints.
That's what I liked it.
Yeah,
that's it.
I,
um,
so when from time to time I'll clean out
my,
just my place.
I believe in just getting cluttered
opens up so many different avenues to
bring other things in.
So I instead of just throwing it all
away,
I make a game out of it.
So I go out to the Pasadena Rose Bowl
and I just sell my shit.
I just sit there in a parking space in
half by myself.
And I fucking sell garbage and my goal
every time is to sell everything.
Whatever I don't sell,
I swing by goodwill,
I'd donate it,
and then I'm out of there.
How much have you made doing that?
Well,
as I would average 350 bucks,
which is solid.
Four or five hour day out there,
having fun,
just yelling at people,
watching the goofs because you see a lot
of.
It's interesting.
It's a weird social experiment because
you see the people that are addicts to
whatever it is,
shoes,
belts,
leather,
whatever.
Then you see people who are addicted to
the sale.
Oh,
that's just too good to pass up.
I don't need that fucking iron,
but it's fifty cents.
I'm buying that motherfucker.
You know what I mean?
And you're like,
wow.
So you see,
you're like,
oh,
okay.
You really like,
you want all my leather goods?
You know,
they'll come run into you for musical
instruments in jeans or the.
That's the first wave of people they're
sprinting through.
You have jj musical instruments.
So I just take shit.
My average was 300 bucks.
I was my,
my daughter's mother.
And we were,
I was like,
I'm just going to sell all our shit and
she's like,
you're not going to make a lot of money.
I'm like,
I'll make at least 350 bucks.
It's a fun day.
Throw toward some baby stuff,
you know.
So I go out and you got to get out there
before the sun's up,
you know,
and,
and you've got all kinds of people out
there.
They're praying to Mecca before the sun
comes up and shit.
You're like,
wow,
this is a whole universe of different
fucking people,
not only the sellers,
the buyers.
And this is the Rose Bowl,
the rose bowl,
always second Sunday of every month yet,
what do they call it?
Pasedena flea market.
And it's at the Rose Bowl.
Do you have to have a license?
You buy a permit and basically your park
at your space as a parking space in a
half.
That's all you get.
It's narrow.
So people are right on top of you.
So I pull the truck in and then I just
set everything up behind it so I can
chill on the truck and I,
I just put blankets down.
I'm like black and I just start yelling
everything.
Like God got cds,
people still need to set up,
ready to do it.
Now
it's so much fucking fun.
So I get out in the lane and also play a
game to a friend of mine.
He would go once in a while and I'm
like,
alright,
let's pick the fucking item.
You should never be able to sell,
but our goal is you got to fucking sell.
And we had had a vhs self prostate exam
of vhs cassette and I was like,
I'm going to sell this.
He's like,
you're definitely not going to sell that
today.
And I packaged it with a little roll
away and I was like,
by the way is a hilarious father's day
prank.
She's like,
that's great.
How much?
I was like a buck bought it,
boom,
but I just get out there and I yell
because I sold a leather jacket,
a nice one,
and this guy came sprinting,
review.
Do anymore leather goods.
I'm like,
I'm not at.
No,
I just had one leather jacket and I'm
like,
I'm out.
Like at.
So my,
my whole thing is I set it all up and I
don't bring plant because you can smell
that a mile away.
So I bring these little brought does
vape pen
and I'm hitting the fucking thing and
I'm hitting the thing and I'm all set
up.
Now I got to a $10 table,
$5 blanket and shit and whatever's
doesn't sell by about 1130 noon.
I start now to $2 blanket.
Now it's a dollar blanket.
Everything's and I'm so.
And then they come running over and
they'll buy books.
I'm like,
can I get four of these for a dollar?
Yup.
So I'm hitting this vape pen and I start
to feel this weird sensation in my chest
and it spreads to my arms and it's
almost like,
like I'm almost powerless.
I can't,
I can't raise my arms.
And I see the circle start to close and
I'm like,
oh no,
I'm by myself.
I'm like,
there's no fucking away.
Breathe through this shit.
And I'm just like,
don't pass out,
don't pen,
I've never passed out.
But that circle was fucking clothes and,
and I caught myself and I was able to
keep with it and I was texting,
you know,
my daughter's model,
I got some shit,
you know,
it's fucking 6:00 AM.
She's dead asleep.
Like if I,
if you don't hear from me in 30 minutes,
you know,
I'm texting weird shit.
So I sell,
I get back to myself and I start selling
shit.
And by the end of that day I fucking
sold the table.
I brought the,
bring this shit on.
I went home with nothing and I get home
and she's like,
how'd you do?
And I go,
not as good as I thought I would because
I thought I'd make 3:50.
So they start telling me that everybody
in the apartment complex have bets
against me of what I would make.
And I was like,
what was the top one,
hundred and 50.
I fucking threw $650 on that table.
I was like,
that's a good motherfucking day out at
the Fort Rosebowl ps almost died.
So I tell my friend about that,
who he grows marijuana.
He smokes from the time he gets up to
the time he goes to bed and I was like,
I'm hitting one of these pens this
weekend at the thing.
He goes,
let me tell you how that ends.
I go,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I hit one this weekend at a wedding.
Same fucking thing.
He went into a seizure.
They took him to a hospital from the
wet.
These people see seizures and I'm like,
what?
He said for a good 15 minutes when they
were like,
you're at the hospital.
He didn't know what a hospital was.
He was like,
he said it took him a minute to come
back to himself and I was.
So I just recently tried a new one
again.
I was like,
let me just try it like an idiot,
but for like a good two weeks I had that
feeling of like I didn't have my
strength.
You know what I mean?
Like I couldn't do it.
Yeah.
It was so weird.
All Cross this vape pen,
what is in the vapor?
What isn't that stuff?
Because there's a bunch of oils and
stuff like that.
They used to a wax it like,
that's what they all tell you.
We can't tell you.
I did talk last podcast a while ago and
I was like,
dude,
you've had a heart attack.
You shouldn't be smoking those pens.
And as I'm telling him that story is
producers got this look in his eye.
Go.
I can tell he's like,
do when have a heart attack.
So a little while ago,
a few years back,
young,
and um,
his producers like step by step,
what you're saying me happened to me.
And
Todd glass it over his shoulder.
I was like,
dude,
get rid of that thing.
Just regular weeds.
Good.
That's it.
Playing.
Stop playing around.
There's no,
you don't need anything else.
Yeah.
The people were always giving me stuff
and I was like,
look,
I just like joints and sometimes I like
balance.
I like balance.
This is the latest thing with tobacco on
the outside.
Yeah.
See,
I don't like that.
I like it.
The thing I never liked about the blunt
was I really liked the taste of weed and
I that old philly's like that wrapper
that it dominates the flavor.
It's like Cilantro,
you know what I mean?
Don't change anything but that.
Yeah.
He's got the shit that stuff is this
stuff.
It's got.
It's got some sort of a nice tobacco
leaf outside,
but powerful.
We'd inside.
You just got to be careful at how many
hits you take.
Yeah,
I bet.
that fucking looks like it gives you
like a little elevated thing too.
Like I had Charlie Murphy was always
into them and that's how I first got
introduced to blunts,
was hanging out with Charlie.
We did a tour together and when we would
get high together,
Charlie was always rolling blunts.
I was like,
all right,
I'll try it.
I was like,
wow,
this is interesting.
I'm like,
it's different.
It's like it's different,
right?
It's different.
It's like it's weird,
but it's also something else.
You know?
It's got a little extra kick,
but yeah,
this,
this pen thing and just people always
trying to find new ways to get fucked
up.
Like there's enough ways they're already
established.
Yup.
It's the,
the,
the jaw joints are the best.
I mean those dot.
I was telling you about those doctors
when we were talking before the show and
the thing he said about smoking a bowl
is just the only thing you have to worry
about.
The butane you're sucking in from the
lighter.
It's not the smoking in glass.
Don't put it in like taste it.
Yeah,
you can.
Absolutely.
I just saw a lighter the other day at a
shop that was a alcohol.
I've never seen that before and I don't
know if that's it.
I don't know if that's any better for
you or not,
but it was an alcohol lighter instead of
a butane lighter.
I imagine it would be better,
but I've used matches before for that
very reason because I could smell.
That's what cigars like.
You're not supposed to light a cigar
with a butane lighter.
They stink and you're supposed to light
it.
They love the real cigar dorks,
they'll take a cigar or or lighter
rather,
and they'll light a piece of cedar and
then the use that piece of Cedar to
light the cigar.
So there's no bullshit,
no bullshit fumes.
They'll take a match light the Cedar and
then take that Cedar Light.
The cigar.
Yeah.
Not to blend fan though,
but I get it.
I've smoked enough of them,
but I'm like,
I really liked the test.
Why?
Like joints?
Because you can taste the weed guy.
I enjoy the taste of marijuana.
I do too.
Especially the California weed stuff
we're getting today.
It's like,
Ooh.
It's nice.
We live in a good time.
We do live in a good spot.
I gotta wrap this up.
It's 3:00.
Ryan.
You're good man.
I'm glad we finally did this program.
Thank you so much to it again.
I would love to tell people that your
podcasts,
cause yeah,
the crab feast.
Go to the craft [inaudible] dot com.
Subscribe every Tuesday out.
And um,
Ryan sickler on all social media.
Ryan.
So where can they catch on tour?
Hilarious.
Standup comedian.
Right now I'm just in La.
I'm at the comedy store actually
tonight.
Eric Bates.
I'm at the store 10:30 tonight.
I'm there next week in the main room at
8:30 and I'm at the holiday on the 14th
and I'm at the Hollywood improv on the
16th.
That's it folks.
Goodbye everybody.
See you fuckers in Chicago.